bien allez mes chers collègues je vous
propose que nous commencions
[Musique]
voilà je
je vais vous inviter à ne pas trop
lancer de discussion entre vous parce
que comme vous le savez dans cette salle
il y a un petit phénomène de résonance
et la salle est petite par rapport au
nombre de personnes dans cette salle
donc dès qu'on commence à
et l'importance de la commission dès
qu'on commence à discuter ça ça s'entend
évidemment
et créer un bruit de fou merci de
d'être attentif à cette préoccupation je
voudrais d'abord souhaiter la bienvenue
à nos cinq invités du jour en commençant
par Monsieur Jean-Philippe thielec et
président du Centre national de la
musique déjà eu l'occasion de dictionner
à plusieurs reprises David el sayek
directeur général adjoint de la SACEM
Guilhem kotec et directeur général de
l'Union des producteurs phonographiques
français indépendants l'UPFI Alexandre
lache qui est directeur général du
Syndicat national de l'édition
phonographique le SNEP Olivier d'Arbois
qui est président du Prodis
je les remercie d'avoir accepté notre
invitation pour évoquer en notre
compagnie l'avenir du Centre national de
la musique en général et celui de son
financement en particulier je sais que
d'autres intervenants potentiels se sont
émus de ne pas avoir été conviés à
participer à cette table ronde qu'il se
rassure nous ne manquerons pas sous une
forme ou sous une autre de les
solliciter dans les semaines à venir
pour participer à la suite de nos
travaux sur ce sujet il me semble
nécessaire de rappeler que le Centre
national de la musique a été créé dans
un rare et désormais lointain un moment
d'harmonie parlementaire la loi du 30
octobre 2019 en effet a été adopté à
l'unanimité par les deux Chambres du
Parlement à l'issue du remarquable
travail réalisé par le plus musicien des
sénateurs ou le plus sénateur des
musiciens je ne sais pas comment on peut
le qualifier genre Hugonnet qui était
rapporteur du texte pour le Sénat
si on analyse ce qui s'est passé depuis
cette création on peut dire que le
navire du CNM à appareillé par gros
temps puisque en effet lancé le 1er
janvier 2020 il a immédiatement dû
affronter une crise qui a failli
emporter tout un secteur
cette naissance tourmentée a permis à ce
nouvel acteur d'acquérir une formidable
dimension en devenant le seul vecteur
d'aide au secteur de la musique durant
la pandémie on avait eu l'occasion
monsieur le Président de de d'en faire
un bilan avec vous suite aux différents
confinements le centre a été doté de
près de 500 millions d'euros pour faire
face aux conséquences de la crise et je
crois de la vie unanime des
professionnels parfaitement remplis
cette délicate mission cependant comme
le soulignait notre collègue Julien
barjoton dans son rapport pour avis du
projet de loi de finance 2022 cet
accueil plus que positif repose
également sur une forme de malentendu le
CNM n'a en effet pas été conçu comme un
financeur du secteur mais plutôt comme
un instrument de structuration de la
profession l'année 2023 devrait être si
l'on peut le dire la première année
normale du CNM
hors d'une part la profession a de
vastes attentes à son égard compte tenu
de son rôle pendant la crise et d'autre
part son modèle budgétaire initial
considérablement plus modeste que les
deux dernières années étaient déjà
fragilisés pour ne pas dire et déjà
fragilisé pour ne pas dire caduque en
effet le rendement de la taxe sur les
billets n'a pas encore retrouvé son
niveau d'avant crise et les organismes
de gestion collective s'ouvrent des
conséquences d'un arrêt de la Cour de
justice et Union européenne du 8
septembre 2020 sur les
irrépartissables qui limitent
sérieusement les fonds qu'elles peuvent
choisir d'allouer au CNM dans ce
contexte troublé l'idée d'une taxation
spécifique fait son chemin sur un modèle
qui n'est pas sans rappeler celui du CNC
d'aucun soutien à cet égard la création
d'une taxe sur le streaming le dépôt
d'amendement en ce sens n'ayant pas
manqué de faire polémique à l'Assemblée
nationale le 30 septembre dernier l'idée
n'est pas aujourd'hui de débattre
spécifiquement du bien fondé d'une telle
taxe mais de prendre au contraire
peut-être un peu de hauteur pour
esquisser les différents scénaris
possibles qui permettront demain au CNM
de fonctionner correctement pour se
faire je vous demanderai monsieur
Thielle de bien vouloir nous brosser à
grands trait la situation actuelle de la
filière musicale de dresser le bilan de
l'action du centre depuis sa création et
développer et d'évoquer ces perspectives
de financement je donnerai ensuite la
parole à missuel ça y est Monsieur kotem
monsieur lâche et Messieurs Darbois pour
nous préciser dans un temps qu'il aura
un parti à se voir 7 minutes
chacun non seulement leurs attentes
vis-à-vis du CNM mais aussi le niveau et
les modalités de financement qui leur
paraissent approprié l'idée étant bien
sûr je lui mettrai vos prises de parole
dans un premier temps pour que nous
puissions échanger avec des questions
qui seront posées par
les sénatrices et les sénateurs je
passerai dans un premier temps la parole
on rapporter des crédits des industries
culturels Julien barjetton puis au
sénatrice et sénateurs de la commission
qui souhaite vous être heureux et les
autres sur le sujet je précise aussi que
Julien barjoton va être nommé parce que
je crois que c'est pas encore officiel
parlementaire en mission sur cette
question parlementaire en mission n'ont
pas auprès de la commission mais auprès
du Premier ministre donc une mission qui
sera confiée par le gouvernement
[Musique]
vous voyez c'est assez facile de mettre
en musique la commission
allez je je vais juste terminer
je vis juste terminé en rappelant que
cette édition est captée et diffusée sur
le site du Sénat et je sais sans plus
tarder la parole au président du Centre
national de la musique pour ouvrir nos
échanges monsieur le président
merci beaucoup monsieur le Président
Madame les sénatrice messieurs les
sénateurs vous avez rappelé monsieur le
Président le lien
d'origine qui existe entre
l'établissement public centre national
la musique et la représentation
nationale et le Sénat et le Parlement
donc
grâce aux travaux préliminaires qui
avait préparé la création grâce aux
travaux qui ont conduit à l'adoption de
la proposition de loi dans le climat de
consensus que vous avez décrit et qui
montrait un aboutissement de près de 40
ans de tergiversations et je veux moi
aussi me joindre
remerciements que vous avez adressé au
sénateur hugonnets en tout cas je tiens
à vous dire qu'au Centre national de
musique on se rappelle l'origine
parlementaire de la proposition de loi
qui a créé l'établissement
dans les minutes même si j'ai noté que
le 7 minutes ne s'appliquait pas tout à
fait au président établissement je vais
essayer de pas trop dépasser pour
essayer de vous brosser en trois points
les questions essentielles qui me
paraissent de voir être portées à votre
connaissance d'abord
sur l'état de la filière
la situation est assez est assez
contrasté
d'abord sur le sur le live nous avons
rendu public jeudi dernier à l'occasion
du Mama les chiffres de fréquentation
des salles en 2021 et sur les 9 premiers
mois de 2022 et on constate que
il y a un recul
modéré de l'ordre de 10% en moyenne je
pars en termes de billetterie mais ce
recul traduit des ce recul moyen donc
traduit des contrastes extrêmement forts
c'est-à-dire que sur l'année 2021 et sur
l'année 2022 nous avons plus de grandes
jauges c'est à dire de stade d'Arena
sous toutes les formes nous en avons
plus qu'en 2019 donc en termes de
billetterie c'est important y compris
parce que ça fait la taxe sur la
billetterie qui est la ressource
essentielle du CNM mais en revanche
tout ce qui est en deçà de ces grandes
jauges souffrent terriblement avec des
baisses qui peuvent aller jusqu'à
-50%. et je vous le rappelle 60% des
concerts qui soutiennent en France se
tiennent dans des salles de moins de 800
places or ce qui compte notamment pour
l'emploi c'est les cacher c'est pas la
recette de billetterie et donc si
l'ensemble de ces de ces salles
souffrent énormément on ne le voit pas
tellement dans les chiffres moyens mais
la réalité notamment dans les
territoires c'est des salles qui sont
gravement fragilisées endettés pour
certaines avec des coûts qui explosent
non seulement bien sûr du côté de
l'énergie avec des factures énergétiques
qui font x 6 x 8 x 12 et pas que sur
l'hiver 22 23 23 24 25 26 puisque la
manière de baisser la facture c'est
d'étaler sur plusieurs années donc c'est
quelque chose d'extrêmement structurant
et très préoccupant mais aussi donc le
coût de l'énergie mais aussi le coût des
transports le coût des matières
premières la difficulté à recruter et
dans les musiques actuelles une hausse
des cachets extrêmement élevée pour des
phénomènes dans le détail desquels je
n'entrais je n'ai pas le temps d'entrer
mais en tout cas ça traduit une forme de
crise des ciseaux avec des ciseaux très
ouverts et qui souffrent de plus en plus
des coups qui augmentent et des recettes
qui baissent ou qui stagne donc
un vrai risque pour les pour l'hiver 22
23 et pour l'année 23
après deux années purement et simplement
catastrophiques 2020 je vous fais pas de
dessin mais 2021 de la même manière et
je vous rappelle qu'au début de l'année
2022 il y avait des interdictions
spectacles le temps passe et on oublie
les vagues et les différentes mesures
mais on a commencé l'année 22 avec des
interdictions de spectacle puis
ouverture de spectacle sans sans barre
et sans restauration dans les lieux de
concert mais c'est de l'année 2022 dont
on parle donc ces trois années
absolument catastrophiques du bon je
reviendrai sur les mesures que nous
avons prises du côté du phono la crise
c'est aussi faites sentir et je
laisserai les collègues
à compléter parce que il y a un lien de
plus en plus fort entre le phono et le
live combien de projets et de disques
enregistrés non plus vivre leur vie
c'est-à-dire se développer rencontrer le
public dans les salles dans les
festivals et ensuite pouvoir générer des
revenus combien de disques ont connu
cette ce soir-là il n'en reste pas moins
et c'est une bonne nouvelle pour tout le
monde que le marché de la musique
enregistrée sont les chiffres
communiqués par par le snap au mois de
septembre ont marqué un une progression
globale de 8,2 % par rapport au premier
semestre 21 avec une progression du
streaming payant et gratuit de 15% et de
streaming par abonnement en hausse de
13%. donc c'est une bonne nouvelle parce
que il y a là des des éléments de
création de valeur qui sont à nouveau
très important
alors sur l'état de la filière il faut
aussi dire que grâce au soutien du
ministère de la Culture et de l'État il
n'y a pas eu de faillite certes il y a
eu des emplois qui n'ont pas été créés
de la valeur qui a été détruite
irrémédiablement ce qui a été perdu a
été perdu mais le paysage est existant
et il n'y a pas eu de catastrophe alors
vous avez eu l'amabilité monsieur le
Président dire que le CNM avait été le
seul financeur dans la crise je crois
que c'est c'est le faire une financeur
principal mais les collectivités
territoriales ont joué le jeu vraiment
l'État dans une certaine mesure aussi
pour certaines parties de ces
compétences et donc l'opérateur a existé
j'ai souvent entendu qu'est-ce qui se
serait passé si CNM n'avait pas existé
mais nous n'avons pas tout de même été
été seul ce qui participent des
inquiétudes parce que j'ai pas évoqué
dans les inquiétudes la question des
financement par les collectivités
territoriales de la vie musicale mais là
aussi les mauvaises nouvelles
s'enchaînent dans le Grand Est en
Auvergne Rhône-Alpes depuis déjà
quelques temps dans certaines villes et
dans certaines métropoles et ça ça
participe à nouveau d'un risque de
d'attrition parce que pour faire des
économies il y a pas d'autres manières
que de moins jouer et donc bon j'insiste
pas davantage deuxième point après ce
point très rapide sur le finance sur
l'état de la filière la question du
financement du CNM mais je voudrais de
la manière la plus claire possible vous
dire qu'en fait il y a pas de question
de financement du CNM il y a des
problèmes de financement de certaines
missions du CNM l'établissement public
son plafond d'emploi qui n'a pas bougé
pendant la crise alors même qu'au lieu
de gérer une cinquantaine de millions on
a un géré 200 par an et je ne peux pas
prendre la parole en public sans dire
que je suis fier de l'équipe que je
dirige parce que parce que les mots que
vous avez eu monsieur le Président il
s'adresse à eux mais il y a pas de
problème de financement du CNM le budget
de fonctionnement et le même depuis
depuis 2020 avec avec la fusion des cinq
structures le plafond d'emploi n'a pas
bougé et c'est la subvention de l'État
qui couvre le budget de fonctionnement
d'environ 18 millions d'euros bon donc
il y a pas de problème de financement du
CNM au sens où il peut y avoir des
problèmes financement d'autres
établissements publics mais là non
j'ajoute que sur le le
rythme de croisière que nous n'avons pas
encore complètement trouvé au CNM nous
sommes installés l'an dernier dans des
locaux dans le 13e arrondissement nous
avons investi sur des différents
systèmes d'information dont bénéficient
les entreprises
et les structures qui sont affiliées au
CNM je crois que l'établissement
fonctionne j'en profite au dit aussi
pour dire que
il y a eu quelques interrogations alors
surtout à l'Assemblée nationale me
semble-t-il sur une prétendue opacité
une prétendue transparent absence de
transparence je sais pas ce que ça veut
dire nous avons un agent comptable nous
avons le CBC administériel nous avons la
Cour des comptes que nous avons vu
beaucoup depuis deux ans et demi toutes
les aides que nous versons sont publiées
en trois clics Mesdames etatrices et
Messieurs les sénateur en trois clics on
tombe sur un tableau Excel qui fait 4491
lignes pour les aides 2021 et 2022 ça
sera au début 2023 donc à nouveau en
terme de transparence un établissement
public le doigt et je crois pas qu'on
pourrait faire beaucoup mieux troisième
point en revanche donc une fois que j'ai
indiqué si quand même un point sur le
financement du CNM ou plutôt sur son
fonctionnement je tiens aussi à dire que
un des sujets importants c'est les
crédits d'impôts nous avons mis en œuvre
depuis déjà novembre 2000 octobre 2020
au nom de l'État nous délivrons les
agréments pour les crédits d'impôts donc
ça aussi il y a pas eu de rupture et
c'est un point extrêmement important
pour tous les toute la filière musicale
le Sénat et l'Assemblée nationale ont
voté l'an dernier un nouveau crédit
d'impôt en faveur des éditeurs de
musique qui n'est pas entré en vigueur
puisque les textes d'applications n'ont
pas été pris
et nous nous sommes nous sommes nous
sommes mais
nous sommes en attente de ce dispositif
alors troisième et dernier point qui je
crois est un point extrêmement important
sur quel besoin
quelle source de financement pour les
missions du CNM
alors quand j'ai indiqué que le
fonctionnement du CNM était assuré je ne
vais pas m'apesantir mais c'est
notamment toutes les missions non
financières du CNM qui n'est pas qu'une
caisse d'aide mais qui fait de
l'observation d'analyse c'est très
important on a travaillé sur l'user
centric on a travaillé sur la place des
femmes dans les festivals en travaillant
en ce moment sur les fausses stream la
manipulation des streams sur les
plateformes etc toutes ces missions là
la formation professionnelle sont
assurés et c'est extrêmement important
face aux grands enjeux auxquels la
filière est confrontée mais il n'en
reste pas moins que sur le volet
financier donc il y a des questions qui
se posent je crois qu'avant de se
demander quelles ressource il faut
trouver il faut partir de des besoins à
quoi ça sert et les besoins c'est des
lignes budgétaires en face des missions
que vous avez votées à l'article 1er de
la loi du 30 octobre 2019 qu'est-ce
qu'il faut faire et depuis le tout début
de l'année 2020 c'est à dire avant la
crise on a concerté avec des
professionnels donc tous ceux qui sont
là à ma droite pour analyser les besoins
quels sont les besoins la filière
contenu de l'évolution des métiers quand
ils opportunités à l'international
compte tenu des de la compétition des
contenus dans lequel nous nous trouvons
qu'est-ce qu'il faut faire pour que la
France donc l'équipe de France de la
musique soit plus forte cette
concertation elle a abouti et y compris
en s'appuyant sur les travaux
parlementaires qui avaient préparé la
création de la loi sur le rapport de
recolivier Mestre sur le rapport de
franquiester et autres comme on dit en
2010 on arrive à un périmètre
d'intervention pour l'établissement
public de une cinquantaine de millions
d'euros je peux pas dire 48,3 ou 51,2
c'est pas une évaluation fiscale en
fonction de je ne sais quoi c'est c'est
un périmètre d'intervention une
cinquantaine de millions d'euros or
fonctionnement de l'établissement et or
droit de tirage parce que le droit de
tirage c'est pas une aide c'est une
entreprise payant elle récupère 66 et ça
échappe je dirais à toute orientation
politique donc une cinquantaine de
millions d'euros pour faire quoi pour
faire du soutien au live naturellement
pour soutenir la diversité pour investir
dans les salles pour
aider au tourner etc etc en tout cas ou
non la diversité
l'essentiel par de là mais aussi pour
aider la filière de du fauneaux dans la
mesure où avec les opportunités qui sont
liées au streaming on voit que
il y a énormément de labels indépendants
partout sur le territoire qui se sont
montés mais qui notamment dans certaines
esthétiques plus fragiles que d'autres
n'existerait pas sans le crédit d'impôt
dont je parlais et aussi sans être
sélective qui auparavant était gérée par
le fond pour la création musicale le FCM
ou qui pour le la projection
internationale était gérée par le Bureau
Export de la musique française
dans ces 50 millions il y a aussi des
sujets tout à fait nouveaux que la loi
avait bien vu mais qui prennent
l'importance capitale qu'on appelle
sujet transversaux la transition
écologique pas besoin de vous faire un
dessin nous avons passé un été un peu
particulier avec l'annulation de
festival pur et simple ici ou là sur le
territoire avec des enjeux sur
l'évolution des modèles y compris dans
le phono d'ailleurs dans la production
et pour lequel il y a besoin d'analyser
d'observer et d'orienter pour aider les
professionnels à prendre ses virages
mais aussi évidemment l'égalité
famome la transition digitale tous ces
enjeux qui sont transversaux sur
lesquels nous pensons que si sa figure
dans la loi c'est bien parce que
l'établissement public à cette
légitimité là alors ces 50 millions on
en est un peu loin pour 2023 en tout cas
aujourd'hui compte tenu de la baisse
modéré quand tout ce que j'ai dit tout à
l'heure mais modéré quand mes baisses
quand même du rendement de la taxe
on estime qu'on va avoir
une trentaine de millions d'euros dont
il faut retirer les deux tiers puisque
c'est du droit de tirage et donc ça fait
une dizaine plus les dotations de l'État
qui a respecté ces engagements plus les
dotations des organismes de gestion
collective qui avant financé les
structures que nous avons fusionnées
mais qui ont subi la crise elles aussi
et qui ont subi l'arrêt rap je vais pas
m'apesantir on avait déjà parlé c'était
une tempête dans le tsunami en quelque
sorte
nous pensons donc que nous arriverons à
une grosse vingtaine de millions d'euros
en 2023 on cache disponible si je peux
m'exprimer ainsi la ministre de la
Culture dont je partage l'opinion a
indiqué à l'Assemblée nationale que avec
quelques sous-consommation sur la fin
des crédits France relance nous
pourrions redéployer ici ou là dans une
mesure que je ne peux pas vous exposer
aujourd'hui parce que on est en pleine
phase de de prévisions d'exécution et de
préparation du budget mais la ministre
avait l'air de penser qu'on arriverait à
une trentaine j'en accepte l'augure bien
volontiers on travaille dans ce sens
avec le ministère de la Culture mais
avec 30 millions d'euros on fait pas 50
c'est à dire que on fera sans doute il
n'y a pas de mission qu'on abandonnerait
vraiment mais au lieu de faire 4
millions et demi d'euros pour favoriser
l'export on va redescendre à ce que
faisait le Bureau Export de la musique
française un million et demi sans doute
sur l'égalité homme-femme on était à 250
000 ans 2020 on était passé à un million
7 en 2022 on sera pas un million 7 alors
même que ce sont à nouveau des
transitions pour lesquelles on peut pas
dire un matin c'est bon on a on a réglé
le sujet
donc mon point c'est que si on arrive en
forçant à cette 30 millions d'euros là
il y aura énormément de projets de
spectacle d'enregistrement qui
n'existeront pas c'est aussi simple que
ça parce que les organismes de gestion
collective je veux pas parler à leur
place ici mais une OGC comme la damine
n'aide plus aucun label discographie à
cause de la crise et de l'arrêt rap de
la Cour de justice il se tourne vers
nous en disant est-ce que vous allez
compenser 25 millions d'euros par an on
les a évidemment pas donc il y a cette
question du financement pour 2023 et
pour 2024 c'est encore pire parce que si
on arrive à 30 ça sera grâce au
redéploiement de somme soit que nous
allons sous consommer soit qu'on va
récupérer j'entre là non plus pas dans
le détail mais en 2024 en tout hypothèse
ça sera fini et donc là le risque qu'on
arrive à un CNM
disons
minorée et très loin des ambitions de la
loi me semble très fort
donc il y a eu beaucoup d'agitations et
je vais en terminer par là il a eu
beaucoup de sujets depuis plusieurs
années avec des propositions de taxes
sur les objets connectés de taxes
Youtube de taxe maintenant sur les
plateformes de streaming moi j'ai
toujours dit que j'étais agnostique si
vous me permettez cette expression c'est
à dire que on a besoin d'une vingtaine
de millions d'euros pour assumer les
missions fixées par la loi
une taxe affectée me semble être une
bonne logique dans la mesure où
ils ont ça échappe aux discussions
interministérielles et puis une taxe
affectée musique qui réa la musique me
semble vertueuse parce que ça permet de
de montrer que l'aval finance la montre
que la diffusion finance la création
mais nous avons estimé avec la ministre
que le sujet pour une taxe streaming
n'était pas mûr en 2023 et pour terminer
par là monsieur le Président après pas
mal d'agitations qui ont pris des formes
que je regrette du reste on a entendu
que le CNM n'était pas le rap c'est
purement et simplement faux peu importe
c'est le passé la bonne nouvelle de ces
derniers jours c'est la mission que vous
avez évoqué qui a été confiée au
sénateur barjoton parce que nous
espérons que dans les six mois de la
mission et bien nous pourrons clarifier
tous ces points et arriver à l'été 23 en
vue du PLF 24 avec un dispositif
consensuel ou pas parce qu'au final
c'est quand même le Parlement qui vote
la loi mais en tout cas qui permettra à
l'établissement d'assumer ses missions
voilà j'en ai terminé monsieur le
Président pardon si j'étais un peu long
merci monsieur le Président c'est
important ce présentation
introductive avec des éléments chiffrés
précis je vais donner la parole sans
plus tarder à Monsieur le Sayeg pour
alors cette fois-ci sept minutes je vais
tâcher les respecter monsieur le
Président je vais éviter de répéter ce
qui a été dit et très bien dit par mon
voisin de gauche
j'ajouterai simplement indépendamment de
la mission de structuration et de
coordination du CNM mais quand même dans
la loi l'idée de promouvoir et la mise
en oeuvre d'une politique ambitieuse et
c'est cette ambition qui nous a tous
porté pour soutenir ce CNM et moi
j'aimerais que cette ambition se
traduise concrètement
je voudrais aussi ajouter un point qu'on
n'a pas ajouté par modestie mon voisin
de gauche c'est que le Sénèque il a joué
un rôle essentiel pendant la crise
comment aurions nous fait moi je vais
vous donner un exemple le fond de
secours pour les créateurs c'est 20
millions d'euros mise à disposition des
créateurs qui ont aidé plus de 8000
personnes les gens qui ne pouvaient plus
vivre qui ne pouvaient plus payer leur
loyer qui nous appelait tous les jours
parce qu'il ne pouvait plus exercer leur
métier c'est à dire principalement le
spectacle vivant qui se retrouvait dans
une situation de détresse et sans l'aide
du CNM d'une part et sans l'aide du
Parlement aussi parce que vous avez
introduit un cinquième critère au titre
l'article l324-17 qui a permis de
débloquer des fonds pour les créateurs
en détresse nous n'aurions pas nous ça
s'aime consacrer aussi également 15
millions pour aider ses créateurs en
détresse donc vraiment le rôle du CNM a
été essentiel pendant la crise et même
après la crise moi je parle aussi des
guichets de bourse aux auteurs un des
aides aux éditeurs qui sont pour nous
essentiel et qui permettent de
développer et de garantir la diversité
culturelle je parvenir aussi sur les
modes de financement ça a été très bien
expliqué et les difficultés aujourd'hui
parce qu'il y a trois sources de
financement dans l'ordre croissant c'est
d'abord le spectacle vivant plus l'état
puis après les organismes de gestion
collective alors je représente un
organisme de gestion collective et
aujourd'hui
le dispositif il est menacé pour
plusieurs raisons
la première c'est qu'on avait eu faire
face à la crise sanitaire la Sacem a
perdu en deux ans tout cumulé 200
millions d'euros de collecte donc c'est
200 millions d'euros en moins pour ses
créateurs et en réalité cette cette
perte cache une autre réalité c'est que
sur le spectacle vivant et mon collègue
de droite l'expliquera certainement
mieux que moi c'est 300 millions d'euros
qui ont été perdus donc une partie a été
compensée par les revenus numériques
parce qu'on a fait mieux en matière de
revenus numériques mais malheureusement
les revenus numériques quand vous passez
un contrat avec un Spotify un Deezer ou
un Apple sur 180 pays c'est pas
forcément le répertoire francophone qui
est le mieux exposé et qui profite de
cette augmentation en revanche en
matière de spectacle vivant c'est
principalement nos talents qui se
produisent en France donc une baisse sur
le spectacle vivant se fait ressentir de
manière beaucoup plus dure pour les
membres de la SACEM on est à notre
niveau le plus bas de répartition depuis
2012 malgré un amortissement de la chute
donc on est dans une situation
compliquée on va d'abord aider les
nôtres et puis par ailleurs vous le
savez le dispositif de rémunération pour
copie privée fait l'objet d'attaque
constante récurrente injustifiée tant au
niveau européen qu'au niveau national
qui met en péril toute la culturel une
année de copie privée je le rappelle
c'est 12000 projets aidés 3000 pour la
SACEM c'est à peu près 70 millions
d'euros pour l'ensemble des OGC si on
prend simplement celle qui interviennent
dans le secteur de la musique c'est 40
millions d'aides donc à chaque fois
qu'on fragilise un dispositif qui
représente 1% du prix d'un iPhone on
remet en cause de nombreuses aides des
festivals à de l'aide à la création à de
l'éducation artistique et culturelle qui
sont par ailleurs aussi des missions que
poursuit le CNM donc c'est très
important aujourd'hui de stabiliser ce
dispositif à ce qu'on pourra pas
contribuer si les menaces cet argent on
doit le dépenser c'est fameux 25 %
ont une petite partie aujourd'hui je le
reconnais au CNM mais si le dispositif
est menacé c'est tout le dis c'est tout
l'ensemble de ce cercle vertueux qui est
mis en péril alors on va on va venir à
la question qui nous intéresse
principalement c'est les sources du de
financement du CNM moi je vais je vais
être très bref je crois que
Jean-Philippe l'a très bien dit d'abord
pourquoi faire il y a une expression de
besoin qui a été faite par le CNM et qui
mérite certainement d'être discuté parce
qu'il faudrait pas donner le sentiment
que certains cherchent à capter la
valeur du streaming alors profit
exclusif et au détriment des autres et
je pense que qui est un peu empoisonné
le débat ces dernières semaines parce
qu'on est directement allé à la case
taxe streaming sans faire un inventaire
très précis des besoins même si le CNM a
déjà
avancé sur la question donc je pense
qu'il est absolument indispensable
justement pour
donner le sentiment que ça sera un
cercle vertueux et le faire les choses
bien de formuler cette expression de
besoin ça c'est le préalable après une
fois qu'on aura déterminé le besoin et
il y a des besoins et on le sait très
bien on va pas se mentir
comment et quel modalité sur la
possibilité d'une taxe streaming pour
nous la question est ouverte pas besoin
d'être un expert en matière musicale
pour savoir que le streaming est la
source aujourd'hui principale de revenus
et de croissance de la musique
enregistrée donc c'est un gisement mais
c'est peut-être pas le seul donc il
faudra aussi s'interroger sur peut-être
d'autres sources de financement on a
parlé la taxe sur les objets connectés
pourquoi pas partir du moment elle vient
pas percuter le le principe de
rémunération pour copy privé parce que
sinon ça servirait à rien en fait ça
s'annulerait de taxes qui s'annulerait
mais moi je suis je suis ouvert à des
contributions je ferai observer que par
exemple pour le CNC et les diffuseurs
traditionnels sont des contributeurs
massifs en financement du CNC mais
pourquoi pas pour le CNM la question
mérite d'être posée je sais pas qu'il
faut le faire en tout cas il faudra se
poser la question
pour nous si on devait aller sur la taxe
streaming et c'est une option qui est
intéressante je tiens à le préciser je
dirais que il faudrait quand même tenir
compte de plusieurs paramètres le
premier c'est que cette taxe streaming
devrait s'appliquer à tous les acteurs
du streaming d'ailleurs j'observe qu'au
sein de la filière il y a un consensus
sur une contribution sur le streaming
mais il y a de vivre des accords sur les
modalités de mise en oeuvre cette taxe
streaming et pour nous ce qui est
essentiel et je le dis il faut
absolument que les plateformes de
partage de contenu les YouTube les
TikTok les Facebook contribuent si taxe
streaming il devait y avoir à cette taxe
il est inenvisageable d'octroyer un
avantage concurrentiel à des plateformes
qui rémunèrent très mal la création le
gézac qui est le groupement européen des
sociétés d'auteurs a publié une étude il
y a deux semaines et d'après les
chiffres européens pas simplement des
chiffres français mais ils sont
concordants avec les nôtres un million
de stream sur une plateforme comme
YouTube ne génère en droit d'auteur que
200 euros et vous savez qu'en moyenne il
y a quatre artistes quatre auteurs
compositeurs qui participent à une
chanson donc vous faites un million de
strings c'est quand même il faut les
faire vous êtes contents vous partagez
si vous êtes quatre royalement
50 euros voilà ça c'est le niveau de
rémunération une plateforme financée
exclusivement par la publicité ce niveau
augmente bien évidemment lorsque vous
avez un abonnement payant il est en
moyenne de 1200 euros pour un million de
stream il peut aller sur un amendement
individuel jusqu'à 2000 euros donc la
moyenne c'est 1200 euros mais sur les
plateformes de partage de contenu qui
appartiennent à des mastodontes du
numérique
à peine de 100 euros donc ces
plateformes doivent participer aux
financement du CNM se pose donc la
question de savoir si les plateformes
éditorialisées doivent également ou
pourrait également participer moi c'est
une question à la fois de d'équité de
logique à partir du moment où on
embrasse le streaming il faudrait
embrasser toute forme de streaming et
pouvoir voir une taxe affectée sur
l'ensemble des revenus je pense aussi
qu'il est important je le rappelle que
le spectacle vivant au sein de la
filière musicale ne soit pas que le seul
contributeur au CNM c'est essentiel
c'est à la fois une question d'équité on
l'a déjà dit mais aussi une question
d'ambition par rapport à une véritable
politique qui irait bien au-delà des
problématiques du spectacle vivant qui
embrasse la musique enregistrée les
plateformes l'innovation il y a
énormément de points qui sont d'ailleurs
transverses moi je veux en prendre un
qui pour moi la priorité des priorités
sélectionnent
de conclure je termine par ça
aujourd'hui grâce au numérique nous
avons la capacité de nous la SACEM
d'appréhender des revenus à l'export ce
qui était une illusion il y a quelques
années un artiste qui génère des streams
dans le monde entier il est il est en
capacité d'être rémunéré par sa société
d'auteur donc pour nous les sports parmi
tous les enjeux ils ont été cités il
faudra choisir aussi ces priorités c'est
comme ça qu'on fait dans la vie
malheureusement on peut pas tout faire
au même moment constitue une formidable
priorité qui réunit l'ensemble de la
filière parce que c'est intéressant
aussi bien le côté music enregistré que
le spectacle vivant j'en terminerai par
là
diagnostic de financement donc on est
vraiment très favorable monsieur
barjetton voilà vous êtes la star de
cette matinée pour votre mission et pour
regarder dans le détail comment on
pourrait envisager une telle
contribution je vous remercie merci
monsieur Guillaume Guilhem
pour lui PFI merci monsieur le Président
bonjour à tous Mesdames et Messieurs les
sénateur et chers confrères et amis déjà
je voulais vous remercier en premier
lieu d'avoir mis sur pied cette table
ronde qui permet d'aborder en toute
transparence ce sujet au combien
important pour la filière musicale
qu'elle financement du CNM de fait on
pourrait considérer et ça aurait
peut-être évité effectivement certains
certaines confrontations que cette
concertation a eu lieu un petit peu plus
tôt quoi qu'il en soit voilà elle arrive
aujourd'hui c'est tant mieux je vais
éviter de de redire ce que mes mes
confrères ont dit de manière très juste
je commencerai simplement par rappeler
que que ce CNM nous l'avons voulu la
filière l'a voulu profondément
intensément pendant de nombreuses années
elle a appelé de ses vœux et depuis le
1er janvier 2020 c'est désormais une
réalité ce dont nous sommes tous
félicités
on s'en est d'autant plus félicité
pendant la crise comme cela a été
pour autant ce projet CNM de notre point
de vue est resté inachevé pour des
raisons qui ont été déjà en partie
évoquées mais évidemment la crise
sanitaire a ralenti quelque part le
l'agenda de cet établissement mais
parfois pour un bien aussi c'est-à-dire
que la effectivement du côté de la
musique enregistrée je parle de ce que
je connais ces aides ont été absolument
cruciales cruciales pourquoi parce
qu'elles ont permis de maintenir un très
haut niveau d'investissement et
d'emplois encore une fois la filière
fonctionne sur deux jambes le spectacle
vivant et la musique enregistré si vous
avez l'une de ces jambes qui est en
arrêt forcé si je puis dire il est
impératif que l'autre jambe continue à
fonctionner pour que lorsque la la crise
est passée de manière globale et que et
que le le corps essaie de refonctionner
il puisse le faire progressivement et
sans sans constater on va dire un
effondrement général
la deuxième raison de cette inachèvement
on l'a dit c'est un schéma de
financement qui reste incomplet à ce
jour
hormis effectivement la dotation de
l'État dont on peut se réjouir qu'elle
soit conforme à la trajectoire
budgétaire prévu initialement en dehors
de la taxe billetterie qui est héritée
dans l'ancien centre national des
variétés
qui vise à soutenir le spectacle
quid de la musique enregistrée
à ce stade elle ne contribue pas et
lasse au budget de l'établissement ou
alors de manière extrêmement marginale
il existe donc une asymétrie entre le
financement par le Live et le
financement par la musique enregistrée
qui selon nous est incompatible avec cet
objectif cette
maison de maison commune de la musique
qui était prévue pour le CNM la musique
enregistrée savait dès le début qu'elle
serait amené à contribuer et selon nous
ce jour-là est venu
plusieurs pistes avaient été évoquées
pour les avant la création de
l'établissement plusieurs pistes de
financement
pourquoi parce qu'on savait que encore
une fois on avait une certaine ambition
on visait une ambition qui était de
d'impulser une dynamique de création et
de production bien plus forte que ce que
pouvait faire en cumuler le FCM le
Bureau Export etc donc une envie une
politique ambitieuse c'est aujourd'hui
ce qu'on continue de souhaiter pour le
CNM mais une politique ambitieuse ça se
finance il faut donc des ressources des
ressources pour effectivement soutenir
ce qu'on a déjà évoqué à savoir
l'observation impartiale de la filière
le soutien financier à la diversité
musicale à l'export à l'innovation
l'aide à la transition écologique et à
l'égalité femme homme etc etc
parmi ces pistes il y en avait une que
nous appelons aujourd'hui contribution
de l'écosystème de la diffusion
numérique au financement de la diversité
musicale afin d'évite de faciliter un
peu les choses on va appeler sa taxe
streaming je crois que dans la presse et
désormais comme ça que ça se considère
et ce que je peux vous dire du côté des
producteurs indépendants c'est que nous
avons regretté que le gouvernement n'est
pas pris l'initiative d'inscrire ce
projet dans le cadre du PLF pour 2023
alors de quoi s'agit-il il s'agit comme
la dit en quelques mots David
d'appliquer à l'ensemble des acteurs
diffusants de la musique en ligne que ce
soit sur un modèle payant ou gratuit une
taxe d'un taux très faible dont le
produit abondera le CNM et lui permettra
de financer les missions que que j'ai
mentionné de notre point de vue la
croissance à deux chiffres constantes du
streaming justifie que ce marché soit
ciblé en priorité pour contribuer au
financement du CNE
il s'agit de notre point de vue d'une
solution pérenne qui est sans incidence
pour les finances publiques et je
précise ça avec beaucoup de de
en phase c'est parce que nous venons de
passer par deux années de quoi qu'il en
coûte deux années et demi et qui nous
semblait important de ne pas solliciter
à nouveau la ressource publique
c'est sans incidence pour les finances
publiques mais c'est au combien
bénéfique pour la création locale pour
la prise de risque artistique pour la
diversité musicale je l'ai dit et
également pour la survie de notre tissu
de TPE
il s'agit d'un mécanisme contributif qui
permettra de corriger les effets de la
seule loi du marché
et de dupliquer tout simplement ce qui
existe notamment pour le cinéma français
depuis des décennies et qui a fait sa
vitalité
il s'agit également de notre point de
vue d'un pari de long terme puisque la
production de nouveautés aujourd'hui
c'est le catalogue de demain
donc si on assèche la production locale
de nouveautés la mauvaise nouvelle à
terme c'est qu'on asséche également le
catalogue des plateformes on trouve un
petit peu étonnant que les plateformes
ne soient pas plus enthousiastes à
l'idée de créer ce mécanisme
redistributif vertueux pour la création
voilà je n'en rajouterais pas plus pour
l'instant afin de
de rester court merci mais je vais
donner la parole à Alexandre lâche
directeur général du
[Musique]
merci monsieur le Président bonjour
bonjour à toutes et à tous mesdames et
messieurs les sénateurs merci pour pour
cette invitation on est honoré je crois
on peut le dire de l'intérêt que vous
portez à ce sujet par votre présence
même nombreuses aujourd'hui donc merci
merci pour votre présence beaucoup de
choses ont déjà été dites je vais je
vais tâcher de ne pas faire de redit
mais de compléter certains des propos de
de mes collègues peut-être en faisant un
petit rappel historique de
la d'où vient notre secteur puisque
aujourd'hui on constate
comme comme l'a fait Jean-Philippe
Thiais comme comme l'a fait Guilhem que
le secteur de la musique enregistrée est
en croissance il l'est depuis finalement
assez peu de temps et d'ailleurs le
retour à la croissance de ce secteur à
peu ouprou coïncider avec la création de
l'établissement
voilà on a vécu 15 ans de crise du
disque que vous n'avez pas pu
ne voir les uns et les autres et qui a
conduit à une destruction de valeur dans
le secteur de 70% environ on a perdu 70%
de notre chiffre d'affaires entre le
début des années 2000 et disons à peu
près l'année 2015 qui est le fond de la
piscine si je veux dire donc
une période extrêmement complexe pour le
secteur qui a fait de la casse à tous
égards de la classe sociale moins de
production mais malgré tout un outil
productif qui s'est maintenu qui s'est
maintenu en grande partie on l'a déjà
cité grâce à un dispositif extrêmement
structurant pour le secteur qui est le
crédit d'impôt à la production
phonographique et j'y reviendrai alors
évidemment le retour à la croissance il
est précieux ils se fonde d'abord et
avant tout sur le pari que les ayants
droits ont fait la SACEM en premier il
faut le dire du nouveau modèle
économique qui est le streaming par
abonnement c'est extrêmement vertueux
comme modèle puisque ça a permis
d'éteindre ou en tout cas de ringardiser
le piratage pour pour le secteur de la
musique ça n'a pas éteint
malheureusement complètement et ça
surtout recréer du consentement à payer
pour pour la musique via ses abonnements
et c'est quelque chose dont évidemment
on se réjouit donc
dans ce contexte la création du Centre
national de la musique a permis de
rationaliser les guichets d'aide et de
créer une maison commune de la musique
avec des missions qui vont bien au-delà
de la simple distribution de soutien
financier donc à l'heure à l'heure de ce
premier bilan il faut constater avec mes
collègues que le CNM a été plus qu'au
rendez-vous de la crise et Jean-Philippe
tu l'as tu l'as dit tout à l'heure cette
crise elle a aussi la crise sanitaire
elle a aussi un impact sur sur la
musique enregistrée puisque là où nous
aurions dû être en croissance rapide en
rattrapage par rapport à cette perte de
valeur que j'évoquais en réalité la
fermeture des commerces culturels à
handicapé le secteur
la perception de certaines de certaines
contributions telles que celle sur les
la diffusion de musique dans les lieux
publics a aussi bien évidemment été
affectés par cette période et nous avons
donc été stables alors que nous aurions
dû être en croissance sur sur cette
période donc le soutien du CNM à
l'endroit de la musique enregistrée il a
été plus que le bienvenu il a permis
justement de rassurer les entreprises et
de leur permettre de continuer à
envisager l'avenir à peu près
sereinement pour poursuivre les
investissements et pour suivre la
production et la création
alors des précisions sur le modèle de de
soutien de notre secteur le Centre
national de la musique ça a été dit à
regrouper
fusionner des associations préexistantes
que sont le fond pour la création
musicale ou le Bureau Export de la
musique entre autres mais qui
intéressait particulièrement le secteur
de la musique enregistrée
le Centre national la musique a
également repris la gestion du crédit
d'impôt pour la production
phonographique mais le soutien du
secteur ces tours c'est aussi
historiquement organisé
par lui-même et notamment par la
contribution des
OGC et la mise en place de guichet
d'aide par ses organismes de gestion
collective aujourd'hui on parle
d'environ 15 millions d'euros distribués
à la profession par la SCPP et la SCPF
qui sont pris sur comme l'a évoqué David
sur des ressources telles que la copie
privée ou les y répartissables alors
bien sûr les aides à la des sociétés de
gestion collectives ont été fortement
affectés par une décision de la Cour de
justice de l'Union européenne nous
savons que la Commission européenne est
le gouvernement français travaillent au
rétablissement de la situation
antérieure ce sera long ce sera complexe
c'est encore un certain mais ça va dans
le bon sens
je souligne cela parce que
pour important pour capital que soit
l'intervention du CNM le secteur a aussi
organisé son sa propre forme de de
soutien direct aux entreprises et il
faut qu'il en soit tenu compte
toujours dans le modèle de soutien à la
musique enregistrée je veux souligner
également
une mesure particulière qui bénéficie au
très petites entreprises du secteur qui
est une mesure issue du fond peps
un fond doté de de 29 millions d'euros
en PLF 2023 et à l'intérieur de ce qu'on
peps une une enveloppe donc qui
bénéficie aux entreprises de moins de 10
salariés du secteur de la musique
enregistrée pour les aider à embaucher
un nombre toujours plus important de
d'intervenants artistique qu'il soit
musicien ou artiste principaux c'est
extrêmement important et jusqu'à une
date très récente nous n'étions pas
certains que cette mesure se poursuive
pour l'année prochaine nous allons
désormais davantage de certitudes après
avoir échangé sur cette question avec le
ministère de la Culture mais je tiens à
le préciser c'est là aussi une forme de
soutien indispensable à la diversité
pour pour les très petites entreprises
du secteur
sur le crédit d'un point la production
phonographique donc désormais géré par
le CNM comme je le disais
le Parlement et nous en remercions à
nouveau à soutenu son renforcement l'an
passé il avait très peu évolué depuis
son origine en 2006 ou plus fort de de
la crise du disque et c'est heureux
qu'il est qu'il a évolué parce qu'il est
là aussi un vrai moyen de de soutien à
la diversité
pour pour vous dire brièvement désordre
de grandeur
le le CIPP représentait depuis 2006 10 à
11 millions d'euros de dépenses pour
l'État il devrait représenter sous
réserve évidemment de l'évaluation qu'on
fera le CNM environ 17 millions d'euros
dans sa version renforcée donc là encore
il y a des éléments positifs
ils ne doivent pas éteindre évidemment
le contexte compliqué qu'on rappelait
mes collègues mais qu'il est
qu'il est important de semble-t-il de
mentionner j'irai très vite parce que le
temps file mais je rejoins la SACEM sur
le besoin d'une expression
d'une expression précisément des besoins
et je salue la mise en place de la
mission parlementaire comme comme l'ont
fait mes collègues parce que certes il y
a de la concertation
OCN elle est permanente via ces
instances mais le fait est que pour
l'instant elle s'est tenue dans un
contexte où évidemment l'établissement
bénéficier de ressources exceptionnelles
et où nous n'étions pas en gestion de
pénurie sur sur les ressources je m'en
tiendrai là puisque je vois vos signes
juste une précision je veux quand même
clarifier pour pour tout ce que
évidemment pas question pour notre
secteur de ne pas être mis à
contribution et devenir compléter le
modèle de financement du du CNM ou de
ses missions mais simplement nous sommes
extrêmement attentifs à ce que cette
mise à contribution ne vienne pas
remettre en cause le modèle sur lequel
on se recons mais viennent au contraire
s'appuyer sur les acteurs qui
aujourd'hui ne retournent pas
suffisamment à la création et
davidlaçage les a cités il s'agit en
particulier des services de partage de
contenu vidéo tels que Facebook Tik Tok
ou Youtube
si Olivier Darbois président du produit
pour terminer la première
alors je vais je vais vous lire un texte
qui rebouclera un petit peu tout ce qui
a été dit ici
pour être dans les 7 minutes monsieur le
président mesdames messieurs les
sénateurs je tenais tout d'abord à vous
remercier pour l'organisation de cette
table ronde qui nous permet
collectivement de rappeler le rôle
essentiel joué par le Centre national de
la musique depuis bientôt trois ans
un rôle tellement essentiel que son
avenir est aujourd'hui au cœur de tous
les débats de la filière musicale la
semaine dernière encore lors du Mama
festival qui rassemble tous les acteurs
de du monde de la musique nous
échangeions sur les défis à venir les
moyens mis en place pour un CNM qui
rappelons-le est encore très jeune
malgré l'expérience acquise pendant la
crise sanitaire
une expérience qui a d'ailleurs montré
toute la légitimité de la création en
2020 d'une vraie maison commune de la
musique à l'image de ce qui a été fait
pour le cinéma
le Prodis que j'ai l'honneur de présider
qui est aujourd'hui la première
organisation professionnelle du
spectacle vivant privé
regroupant 400 entreprises producteurs
diffuseurs exploitant de salle et
organisateurs de festival et c'est
important de vous dire les quatre
métiers qui sont intrinsèquement
indispensable entre eux qui fonctionnent
d'ailleurs entre ces quatre métiers
c'était d'ailleurs mobilisé pendant
plusieurs années pour la création d'une
telle instance jugée indispensable à la
cohésion et au renforcement de la
filière
je peux vous dire que la gestion de la
crise sanitaire pour le CNM seulement
deux mois après sa création et alors que
le secteur du spectacle vivant était à
l'arrêt complet je le répète à l'arrêt
complet pendant 2 ans
cette cette création n'a fait que
renforcer cette conviction
dans un contexte difficile et disons le
tendu le CNM a fait preuve d'une agilité
incroyable permettant d'accompagner et
même de sauver tout un secteur qui
subissait encore des restrictions comme
l'a dit Jean-Philippe au premier
trimestre 2022
néanmoins le CNM n'a pas vocation être
uniquement le pompier de la filière
musicale bien au contraire il a des
missions précises qui lui ont été
confiées par la loi les dizaines et il
est désormais tant de lui donner les
moyens de les remplir dans un contexte
nécessairement bouleversé
bouleversé d'abord par la crise
sanitaire et sur ce point je crois qu'il
est important de ne pas confondre
reprise et relance
certes le secteur se relève
progressivement mais il doit être encore
accompagné dans sa prise de risque car
la reprise est sous tension
également par les enjeux plus
structurels qui touchent toute notre
filière en effet nous n'ayons pas les
mutations profondes que connaît le monde
de la musique numérique transition
écologique compétences nouvelles
accompagnons-les plutôt pour le secteur
du spectacle vivant par exemple
l'évolution du live dans notre société
est au centre de nos réflexions et nous
savons d'ores et déjà que nous allons
devoir opérer notre propre transition
ce n'est d'ailleurs pas anodin si nous
parlons parfois de 2023 comme l'année
zéro du CNM celle qui lui permettra en
fin de déployer toute sa puissance pour
répondre à des transformations de fonds
or chacun le sait un tel objectif n'est
atteignable que si les moyens
nécessaires pour l'atteindre sont mises
en place ce constat est évidemment pas
n'est pas bon ce constat n'est
évidemment pas qu'une marotte du Prodis
même si rappelons-le nous avons toujours
alerté les pouvoirs publics sur
l'importance de prévoir un financement
pérenne pour le CNM afin d'éviter le
syndrome de la coquille vide
c'est en effet aussi une réalité
rappelée à plusieurs reprises par le
président du CNM Jean-Philippe Thiais
que les choses soient claires un budget
du CNM en 2023 ne sera pas à la hauteur
des enjeux et de son ambition initiale
alors que faisons-nous devant nous
sacrifier certaines actions au risque de
renier sur la diversité musicale ou sur
notre souveraineté culturelle française
ce serait un contresens dès lors face au
constat partagé selon lequel le CNM a
besoin de ressources supplémentaires
pour assurer ses missions nous avons
réfléchi collectivement à la façon
d'assurer un financement solide mais
surtout équilibré
car maison commune ne veut pas dire
maison témoin après l'avoir construite
il est essentiel de la consolider de la
préserver mais surtout d'y inclure tous
les acteurs pour qu'ils s'y
s'entraînement chez eux l'idée n'est
certainement pas de créer une multitude
d'index autour de cette maison
vous le savez tous l'idée d'une taxe ou
contribution streaming pour renforcer le
financement du CNM n'a pas fait
l'unanimité or je veux le redire très
clairement nous avons besoin de tout le
monde pour développer ce projet culturel
français ainsi nous acteurs du spectacle
vivant nous avons besoin de la musique
enregistrée et nous travaillons déjà
avec elle au quotidien depuis de très
très longues années
néanmoins aujourd'hui la symétrie dans
le financement du CNM pose un problème
réel en dehors de l'État une partie du
spectacle vivant et le seul financeur du
CNM via la taxe sur la billetterie
or ce n'est plus tenable pour une
instance qui regroupe tous les acteurs
de la filière musicale dans son
périmètre c'est dès lors une question
d'équité
c'est pourquoi nous sommes plusieurs
acteurs du spectacle vivant comme du
secteur phonographique à défendre une
contribution des plateformes en ligne du
streaming musical cela permettrait ainsi
à tous les secteurs de la filière qui
sont éligibles aux actions du CNM de
partager aux charges de la maison
commune
preuve que le défi immense madame la
Première ministre vient de confier au
sénateur Julien Bargeton que je salue
ne vous interrompez pas
si on parle en commentaire sur le
financement de la filière musicale avec
un volet consacré au CNM
les résultats de cette mission seront
évidemment très attendu
en attendant des amendements ont été
portés par
en attendant des amendements étaient
portés par vos collègues députés sur le
sujet mais l'examen avorté du projet de
loi de finances ne permettra
certainement pas d'avoir une discussion
à bâtons rompu dans l'hémicycle
nous verrons si le Sénat s'en empare de
son côté
je terminerai simplement par dire que si
l'État a été au rendez-vous dans la
création du CNM il doit désormais être
au rendez-vous de son développement je
vous remercie merci messieurs pour cette
présentation luminaire qui est je crois
très claire et qui pose bien les termes
des problématiques auxquelles la filière
est confrontée auquel bien sûr nous
sommes évidemment très attentifs alors
sans plus tarder je vais donner la
parole à Julien barjoton qui va
intervenir entre
qui va intervenir en tant que rapporteur
des crédits des industries culturels de
notre commission
merci merci monsieur le Président merci
à vous je sens une une légère pression
sur les épaules tel Atlas mais enfin on
va essayer de tenir le ciel musical sur
sur nos épaules et d'ailleurs je le
prends cette nomination je crois que moi
je voudrais la partager aussi avec cette
commission c'est pas anodin si c'est le
choix d'un sénateur qui a été fait par
la première ministre et je sais pouvoir
m'appuyer sur cette commission aussi ces
travaux notamment et en particulier
l'expertise des uns des autres que
j'écouterai que j'additionnerai et je
voudrais rendre hommage aussi à
jean-franc à Jean Raymond Hugonnet parce
que je sais que je pourrais compter sur
lui pour autant il faut séparer les
choses il s'agit d'une mission
ministérielle donc faut pas faut pas
mélanger les genres mais pour autant il
y a un point de départ qui est déjà vous
l'avez dit une documentation notamment
du Sénat qui est qui est important alors
le sujet sur la filière c'est
un sujet de besoin d'identification des
besoins moi je voudrais revenir d'abord
sur peut-être que vous pourriez
détailler un peu les grandes tendances
du secteur et notamment sur les
esthétiques musicales où en est-on de la
diversité des esthétiques musicales ou
en est-on de la part du local de la de
en France puisque ce qu'on entend
souvent dire c'est que finalement malgré
les quotas la musique locale et parfois
moins écoutée en France que dans
d'autres pays comme le Japon par exemple
la Corée etc on connaît la K-pop est-ce
qu'on peut revenir un peu sur ce sujet
de de la part de la création française
dans notre pays et en parallèle de
l'export vous avez beaucoup parlé
d'export qu'est-ce qu'il faut faire
puisque vous avez parlé des besoins
qu'est-ce qu'il faut faire pour
renforcer la capacité d'exportation de
la création musicale française ça c'est
le c'est le premier point et puis aussi
ce que vous pouvez nous dire de manière
générale sur la sur la filière vous avez
évoqué Monsieur le Directeur du CNM la
hausse des cachet et vous n'êtes pas
revenu sur l'explication en disant bon
j'ai pas le temps d'y revenir vous
pouvez effectivement aussi détailler un
peu certaines des évolutions que vous
avez évoqué deuxième point le Centre
national la musique vous êtes tous
élogieux sur son action et je crois que
nous pouvons l'être chaque année j'ai
rendu hommage à vos équipes dans mes
rapports parce que elles ont accompli un
travail
exceptionnel dans un temps record et je
crois qu'il faut le souligner parfois on
est critique sur l'action publique mais
quand l'action publique est agile et est
capable de s'adapter il faut aussi
savoir le dire son rôle c'est donc de
rassembler aussi la filière d'être un
peu un fédérateur d'être un lieu
ressources comme vous l'avez dit quels
sont les évolutions là aussi est-ce que
dans son rôle comment on pourrait le
faire évoluer faut-il d'ailleurs revoir
aussi ça sa gouvernance parce qu'on
parle beaucoup de questions de
financement mais faudrait-il aussi
peut-être aborder les sujets de
gouvernance de la filière et pas
simplement peut-être du CNM mais dans
son ensemble le CNM et l'interlocuteur
principal mais vous l'avez tous ce n'est
pas l'interlocuteur unique autre sujet
et je vais essayer d'être bref pour que
mes collègues puissent s'exprimer il y a
le sujet de financement j'ai bien
compris les attentes qui sont sur cette
question là et j'ai vu l'actualité mais
donc il faudra bien sûr répondre à cette
question étant entendu que les outils
doivent correspondre à la réalité de
l'état des lieux un diagnostic et à la
réalité des besoins mais il y a d'autres
outils il y a le crédit d'impôt
également où les crédits d'impôts là
aussi quels sont vos attentes sur ces
sujets là est-ce que
en parallèle du sujet des taxes il y a
aussi le sujet des recettes existantes
et des dépenses puisque un crédit dépôt
c'est une dépense une dépense fiscale
mais c'est bien une dépense et donc
quels sont les évolutions que pourrait
connaître le crédit d'impôt notamment
par exemple pour là aussi renforcer un
certain nombre d'entreprises du secteur
d'entreprises petites ou voilà voilà ce
que je voulais dire
effectivement de vouloir effectivement
se rassembler au sein de cette maison
commune la gouvernance de
l'établissement dans les modalités
devraient être déterminées par voie
réglementaire
comme son financement dont la discussion
est renvoyée au prochain projet de loi
de finance qui cristallise en effet les
inquiétudes du secteur c'est donc pas
nouveau
et depuis
44 ans que je pratique ce beau métier de
musiciens j'ai l'impression de vivre le
film Un jour sans fin pour ceux qui
l'ont qui l'ont vu et l'heure est grave
l'heure est grave non ça fait sourire
oui oui bien sûr mais je pense que
l'heure est grave alors vous excuserez
peut-être de faire parler un peu plus ma
casquette de musiciens que de sénateurs
je m'en excuse auprès de vous monsieur
le Président et chers collègues mais il
m'est impossible de faire autrement
alors je voulais dire la chose suivante
on sait que le secteur de la musique est
depuis longtemps en profonde mutation je
rappelle quand même que c'est le secteur
artistique qui le premier le premier non
seulement artistique mais ça couvre
d'autres champs a connu la révolution
numérique et il l'a pas connu vous
faisiez référence à la diffusion
mais il l'a connu surtout dans ce qu'il
y a de plus important dans la musique
chers collègues et qu'on oublie trop
souvent c'est à dire les créateurs
eux-mêmes
ont eu à faire face à une révolution
numérique
et ils se sont parfaitement adaptés et
ils ont guidé nos vies
musicales et nos vies tout court puisque
la musique c'est la vie depuis ce
moment-là avec intelligence et en
sachant rebondir à chaque fois et en
trouvant parce que ce sont des créateurs
les moyens de nous faire vibrer
alors aujourd'hui je suis à la fois très
heureux et excessivement agacé
très heureux parce que j'ai vraiment le
sentiment
qu'avec la création du CNM on a franchi
un pas très important pour la musique et
pour la vie c'est pas uniquement pour un
secteur musical mais retirer la musique
d'autres l'ont dit brillamment avant moi
notamment Victor Hugo mais s'il n'y
avait pas la musique que serait nos vies
que serait nos vies
en revanche en revanche dès qu'il s'agit
d'industrie
là c'est un agacement véritablement un
agacement pourquoi parce que ce métier
il est
irrigué j'allais dire presque par des
lignes de fracture énorme
alors tout le monde s'embrasse
hein ça c'est la partie du spectacle sur
scène et puis il y a en coulisse sur
scène tout le monde s'embrasse
ici même peut-être autour de la table
mais entre la musique enregistrée et le
spectacle vivant
pour avoir la chance d'être sur scène
depuis quelques depuis quelques temps le
week-end je peux vous garantir que c'est
pas forcément l'amour fou entre le
secteur subventionné
et le secteur privé
là c'est pas un gouffre qui
entre les musiques savantes et les
autres j'en parle même pas entre les
pratiques professionnelles et les
pratiques amateurs
alors il y a la nécessité d'une culture
commune je vais essayer de faire vite
monsieur le Président mais sincèrement
par rapport à d'autres débats ou des
monopolisations de la parole peuvent
être voilà je vais un tout petit peu
plus long un tout petit peu plus long
bien sûr tout le monde va avoir le temps
je respecterai la partition
mais le problème de financement monsieur
le Président vous l'avez dit tout à
l'heure et encore une fois merci pour ce
que vous développez avec vos équipes
depuis la création du CNM vous dites il
n'y a pas de problème de financement oui
sur la structure de base sera structure
de base
ce qui est très intéressant et qui est
fondamental mais c'est pas elle qui est
la plus intéressante la plus
intéressante c'est l'avenir c'est ce
dont on parle aujourd'hui dont on
devrait parler déjà depuis un bon moment
et là pour mettre autour de la table
les musiciens là c'est plus compliqué
pourquoi parce que quand le temps se
couvre chacun pense à sa chapelle c'est
un réflexe humain normal
et moi je souscris parce que encore une
fois le CNM vient d'être créé et c'est
une excellente chose
vous me verrez aussi
défendre s'il n'en ai besoin la SACEM
qui existe depuis bientôt deux siècles
quand même dans notre pays dont on peut
avoir une certaine fierté pour dire que
si je partage monsieur le Président
votre vision sur les objectifs
transversaux je n'ai rien contre la
transition écologique rien contre
l'égalité homme-femme mais il y a juste
des urgences monsieur le Président elles
ont été développées par Daniel David el
saiag pardon elles sont très claires ce
sont les créateurs et l'export donc
j'aimerais que vous nous expliquiez si
réellement vous avez ce sens de
l'urgence
chevillé au corps et comment vous allez
pouvoir le l'exploiter je voudrais
savoir aussi pourquoi une une réflexion
n'a pas pu aboutir avant que n'arrive
sur la place publique forcément des
tiraillements et c'est normal entre
membres du secteur mais que ces
tiraillement arrive sur la place
publique alors même qu'on a besoin
d'union et qu'on n'est pas capable de la
faire je trouve ça contre-productif
dernière question comment puisque vous
l'avez évoqué aussi comment et qu'on est
dans l'assemblée des territoires comment
percevez-vous réellement la place des
collectivités territoriales parce
qu'elle est importante j'aimerais que
vous puissiez l'approfondir
merci je précise que un jour sans fin le
film qui a mentionné Jean Raymond
Hugonnet se termine bien à la fin
alors je
vous laisse répondre à ces premières
séries de questions et puis après les
autres sénateurs intervenants bien
volontiers de manière à le plus rapide
possible parce qu'il y en a beaucoup des
questions les questions du sénateur
barjoto alors sur la diversité musicale
c'est une question extrêmement
importante la part de la création
musicale sur les plateformes de
streaming sur les autres moyens de
diffusion de la musique
de fait nous avons repris les missions
qui étaient assurées avant par le CNV en
lien avec le CSA désormais c'est le CNM
mais
qui reprend ses missions d'observation
et nous allons rendre public dans
quelques semaines l'observation à
diversité à la radio à la télé et aussi
pour la première fois sur les
plateformes de streaming donc je peux
pas non plus vous donner les résultats
parce qu'on est en cours d'analyse mais
c'est une question de semaine ce qui est
clair c'est que
dans notamment sur les plateformes de
streaming qui constituent le mode de
développement de création de valeur
majoritaire il y a un vrai sujet
c'est la question de la découvrabilité
et de la visibilité des productions
locales
l'autre jour j'ai dit qu'il y avait 70
000 titres nouveaux qui étaient mis
chaque jour en ligne sur les plateformes
de streaming et le responsable de 10h
m'a repris en disant 70 miles et il y a
quelques mois maintenant c'est 100000
par jour 100000 titres nouveaux par jour
sur Deezer sur Spotify et sur les autres
donc dans ce dans cet océan comment
émerger comment quelles responsabilité
pour les algorithmes et pour les
plateformes dans l'éditorialisation quel
rôle dans la diversité alors sur les
écoutes nationales je laisserai
peut-être mes collègues en dire
davantage mais il y a une belle
visibilité pour de la production locale
mais qui est ultra concentré sur
quelques genres qui sont les la musique
toutes les étiquettes en matière de
musique ne vont pas donc si je dis
urbain ça va pas parce que bon mais vous
comprenez c'est du hip-hop du rap qui
qui ont la plus grande la plus grande
part mais cette question là
c'est la découvrabilité sachant que sur
les chiffres que nous avons sur le Top
le top 10000 on voit que le hip-hop et
le rap représente un quart des écoutes
et la majorité est représentée par de la
variété internationale notamment
anglo-saxonne et ce qu'on appelle le
Back catalogue c'est-à-dire les titres
qui ont un certain âge parfois pas très
vieux mais quand même bon donc il faut
pas se concentrer sur le top 100 ou le
top de sens c'est une c'est une c'est
une erreur de un prisme disons bon voilà
sur la diversité deuxième point
renforcer l'export ça ça me paraît quand
même assez simple en réalité parce qu'on
a des artistes fantastiques on a des
professionnels qui connaissent leur
métier et donc il faut
s'appuyer sur ce que le Bureau Export
créé par les pros et soutenus par l'État
avait fait c'est maintenant dans le CNM
et donc c'est aussi bête que traduire
des des paroles traduire des livrets de
disques traduire du matériel de
promotion traduire des supports digitaux
de de présent sur les réseaux sociaux et
donc ça fait partie des dépensés
éligibles à la fois dans les et dans les
aides du CNM on était à 5000 concerts
réalisés en 2019 par des équipes
françaises
on doit pouvoir être à 10000 à 15000
parce que il y a de la musique électro
où il y a pas le problème de la langue
mais il y a la chanson mais il y a les
musiques d'aujourd'hui il y a le
classique qui a un vrai vecteur de
création de valeur et donc là je dirais
que si on n'a pas les moyens de soutenir
on passera à côté d'un formidable outil
de rayonnement de développement
ose des cachets je suis pas sûr d'être
le mieux mieux placé pour en parler mais
peut-être que Olivier Darbois précisera
nous ce qu'on nous dit c'est que du côté
des musiques actuelles il y a des hausse
des cachets de l'ordre de 25% pour les
artistes internationaux d'abord qui ont
exercé une forme de de pression avec des
artistes nationaux qui ont suivi pour
des avec des motivations que je
qualifierais comme chez sénateur
hugonnets de l'humaine
mais qui pose des problèmes en termes de
soutenabilité
je note que dans le classique il y a
plutôt une tendance à la baisse
trois alors autre série d'éléments un
lieu fédérateur est sur la gouvernance
je crois que la gouvernance du CNM
fonctionne
c'est assez original des dizaines de
groupes de travail un conseil
professionnel de 40 membres pourrait
presque être un peu plus nombreux pour
représenter la facture instrumentale
pour représenter tel ou tel secteur qui
indéniablement fait partie de la chaîne
de production de valeur mais qui est
peut-être pas assez représentée au CNM
alors c'est dans le décret c'est pas
dans la loi mais en tout cas c'est la
question de gouvernance et le constat
d'administration de 25 membres pour moi
la gouvernance du CNM fonctionne et
c'est assez agile quoi que quoi que
complexe il y a un point c'est que le
lien avec le classique n'est pas
clarifié ça fait partie des ambiguïtés
que la loi n'avait pas réglé et qui est
une question qui est posée au ministère
de la Culture qui n'est pas représenté
aujourd'hui il y a la question de la
taxe que ne paye pas le classique est
une question qui mériterait d'être
creusée qui ne l'a pas été
sur lequel les acteurs du classic
avaient interrogé le ministère qui à ma
connaissance pas répondu c'est une
question qui est pas évidente avec des
enjeux symboliques plus que financiers
des enjeux juridiques aussi mais le CNM
monsieur le sénateur je sais pas si
c'est un jour sans femme et c'est plutôt
un long dimanche de fiançailles parce
que ça a commencé il y a 40 ans et
bon ça se termine bien aussi un long
dimanche de fiançailles mais enfin voilà
enfin sur les questions
[Musique]
posées par
le sénateur hugonnais sur le sens de
l'urgence
je suis d'accord avec vous il n'y a pas
de musique sans compositeur quel que
soit le le nom qu'on donne à ce créateur
là
simplement je pense que un outil de
politique publique ne peut pas
aujourd'hui négliger évidemment donc
l'élection de diversité qui est
essentielle parce qu'on vit dans un
monde concurrentiel on vit dans un monde
où quelques acteurs qui relèvent plus de
l'épicerie universelle que la création
musicale pourrait décider de rayer d'un
trade plume le paysage musical français
je le dis comme je le pense et où la
musique sera un alibi pour vendre des
barils de lessive alors que la musique
est un n'est pas un produit comme un
autre c'est ma conviction mais un
établissement puis comme le ne peut pas
non plus dire que la transition
écologique est secondaire parce que à
nouveau on a vécu un été avec des
annulations pure et simples et donc ce
sont ces aides là que nous étions de
calibrer
pourquoi des tiraillements tout
simplement parce que les questions sur
lesquelles je vais terminer Monsieur le
Président qui que le sénateur barjoton
doit clarifier de mon point de vue dans
les six prochains mois non pas été
creusés par les aides par
l'administration de l'État ministère de
la culture mais aussi ministère des
Finances et que 100 ans l'arrivée
d'amendement parlementaire à l'Assemblée
nationale certains se sont dit on va
dégainer
humain trop humain je le regrettais
c'est pas la peine d'y revenir puisqu'on
est passé à une autre phase mais en tout
cas dans la gouvernance du CNM c'est pas
des choses qui sont souhaitables et j'ai
dit que tout ce qui a faiblissait le CNM
affaiblissait en réalité la filière sur
la place des collectivités territoriales
nous avons une action très déterminée
pour signer des conventions des contrats
avec les régions maintenant les
métropoles on a une toute toute petite
équipe pour faire ça c'est un peu à la
bonne volonté des élus que je rencontre
ça a marché avec Clermont-Ferrand c'est
en train de marcher avec Montpellier
avec Le Havre je parle des métropoles
j'ai signé avec la région Centre
bon donc voilà je pense que ça
fonctionne ça fonctionne bien et c'est
un outil de levier tout à fait
fondamental et donc dernier pour
terminer Monsieur le Président je pense
qu'il faut Serrier les questions dans le
travail parce que si on repart sur les
questions de légitimité pourquoi etc je
pense qu'on va perdre du temps en clair
j'ai entendu Alexandre là je dire
à quelques mots près on ne remet pas en
cause l'idée une contribution des
entreprises à la diversité tant mieux il
faut que la valve finance l'amant il
faut aller techniquement aller voir
comment ça se passe comment ne pas tuer
ou affaiblir certaines entreprises y
compris dans le streaming dont on a
besoin pour créer de la valeur lclm veut
pas affaiblir qui que ce soit dans la
musique européenne est-ce qu'il y a des
moyens juridiques pour cibler tel
secteur plutôt qu'un autre ou tel
segment plutôt qu'un autre c'est en
créer de rupture de d'égalité comment
déterminer l'assiette de taxation sur le
gratuit
parce qu'il faut prendre le payant qui
est un mode vertueux et il faut pas
négliger le gratuit qui est un mode
moins vertueux comme David hassaï l'a
expliqué comment on détermine cette
assiette là il y a un précédent qui est
la TAC YouTube du CNC
probablement avec des faiblesses
juridiques que je ne que je ne connais
pas il suffirait à mon avis pas de
baisser un
d'abaisser un abattement pour upso facto
créer une source de financement pour le
CNL mais c'est des questions qui sont de
législation fiscale et
la qualité de demande de la Cour des
comptes du sénateur barjoton j'ajoute
encore un petit peu à sa pression me
paraît à nouveau
plein de bons de bonnes promesses pour
la conclusion de de ce de ce travail
mais c'est une sorte vraiment un travail
technique qu'il faut réaliser le CNM est
à votre disposition pour cela et un
dernier mot on parle de 20 millions
d'euros on parle de 20 millions d'euros
20 millions pour une filière qui pèse 10
milliards il y a 300 000 personnes qui
gagnent un peu qui tirent des revenus
millions c'est rien je veux pas faire de
comparaison par rapport à d'autres
établissements publics d'autres filières
mais c'est l'épaisseur c'est l'épaisseur
du trait en réalité et si on le fait en
2023 on aura vraiment donné la pleine
ampleur à la loi que vous avez votée il
y a 3 ans bien fait de rappeler ses
chiffres est-ce que vous les compléter
monsieur lâche
merci monsieur le Président quelques
compléments en réponse à monsieur le
sénateur barjoton sur la place de la de
la création française dans la
consommation
nous observons évidemment ces éléments
avec intérêt Jean-Philippe le rappelait
il ne s'agit pas de s'en tenir
au top et ça n'est pas ce que nous
faisons mais malgré tout quand on
regarde les classements des meilleurs
ventes ça donne une indication sur la
locomotive et c'est un motif de fierté
aussi il faut le rappeler depuis
l'avènement des plateformes de streaming
systématiquement 17 à 19 des 20
meilleurs ventes de l'année sont des
artistes français produits en France et
chantant en français et si on regarde de
manière beaucoup plus profonde ce qu'on
a fait
la récemment sur un top 50 000 qui
représente l'essentiel de la
consommation et bien on s'aperçoit que
la consommation sur les plateformes de
streaming est porté à 80% par des titres
de moins de 10 ans donc des titres
récents qui font l'actualité musicale et
dont 62 % sont produits en France donc
là aussi un vrai motif de fierté pour
pour la création française de de musique
et peut-être une différence avec
d'autres industries culturelles puisque
effectivement la création locale est
extrêmement dynamique et lorsque le
public a le choix il se tourne en
priorité vers vers la chanson française
voilà un autre élément peut-être pour
répondre également à monsieur le
sénateur Gonesse sur la question de la
rémunération des musiciens je tiens à
signaler que après des années une
dizaine d'années de débats dans la
filière nous avons conclu avec les
partenaires sociaux et les organismes de
gestion collective représentant les
artistes un accord majeur en mai dernier
ce qui porte sur la garantie de
rémunération minimale c'était une
commande du législateur depuis 2016 je
ne reviens pas sur les débats compliqués
qui s'en sont suivies mais nous sommes
parvenus à un terrain d'entente qui qui
n'est pas la fin de quelque chose mais
le mais le début d'une relation apaisée
avec les musiciens sur la question de
leur rémunération dans le cadre des
exploitations en streaming donc là aussi
des éléments positifs à cet égard
[Musique]
merci monsieur le Président je voudrais
aussi répondre à la question de monsieur
le sénateur sur la part du local je suis
tout à fait d'accord avec ce qu'a dit
Alexandre relâche localement la chanson
française ou la production locale
fonctionne
elle fonctionne plutôt bien mélanger
n'est pas tellement localement les
quotas ça marche monsieur le sénateur je
me souviens que le sénateur qui
s'occupait en 2016 de la loi sur les
cottas nous avait expliqué qu'on avait
pondu une usine à gaz à l'usine à gaz
elle a fait plus 15 % d'artistes
francophones exposé en 5 ans donc ça
fonctionne mais l'enjeu comme vous
l'avez souligné monsieur sénateur c'est
pas tellement localement c'est ailleurs
et là il y a encore énormément de
progrès à faire moi je vous donne un
chiffre neutre balance commerciale elle
est déficitaire là ça c'est mon envoi à
peu près 120 millions d'euros
à l'étranger sur nos sociétaires sur les
sociétés représentées par les sociétés
soeurs notamment américaine et anglaises
et on reçoit 80 millions de d'étrangers
donc c'est moins 40 millions c'est ça
qu'il faut combler c'est ça l'enjeu
aujourd'hui moi je vais vous donner un
autre chiffre qui permet vraiment de
toucher du doigt la problématique de
l'export les chiffres de l'export pour
la SACEM c'est 9% de ses revenus notre
homologue britannique c'est 30% de ses
revenus notre homologues les doigts
c'est 25% de ses revenus et je discutais
pas plus tard qu'hier avec nos
homologues coréens ils sont très
contents parce que qui l'eût cru que les
artistes chantant en coréen puissent
remplir aujourd'hui plusieurs stades de
France il y a 10 ans on aurait tous
rigolé autour de la table en se disant
que c'est quelque chose de très exotique
de très agréable mais ça peut en dehors
des instituts ça peut pas aller plus
loin aujourd'hui quand vous discutez
avec les enfants de la musique qu'ils
écoutent des biens culturels qui
consomment c'est pas les États-Unis qui
les font rêver c'est la Corée et le
Japon c'est c'est toute cette culture
qui a déferlé chez nous et ils ont du
talent donc il faut aussi saluer
l'action qui a été menée par ces pays et
c'est pas c'est pas par hasard si je
fais une exprimer ainsi que ces artistes
aujourd'hui rencontrent le succès il y a
eu un véritable travail il y a
l'équivalent d'un Bureau Export dans ces
pays et qui fonctionne qui a parié qui a
mis de l'argent qui a investi et qui
récolte aujourd'hui les fruits de ses
investissements et on est capable en
français
ou dans d'autres langues de faire la
même chose on a des artistes qui
s'exportent même en français je tiens à
le préciser ce n'est pas une barrière la
langue donc voilà je pense que l'enjeu
pour nous grâce au numérique c'est de
pouvoir faire rayonner nos artistes
au-delà de nos frontières
monsieur coté oui j'aimerais juste
rajouter un point sur la question de la
production locale et la diversité
quand on parle en fait les deux les deux
doivent être liés on parle de production
locale versus versus le l'international
là-dessus il y a des chiffres qui sont
assez divergents selon les sources je me
souviens d'une d'une étude du CNM sortie
l'année dernière sur le user centric qui
faisait état sur Spotify d'une part de
marché de l'international 60%
60%
encore une fois tout ceci légitime le
fait que le CNM doit s'emparer de
l'observation à partiel de la filière et
produire des études qui soient qui soit
consensuelles et pour cela il faut
effectivement du financement mais le la
deuxième chose c'est s'agissant de la
diversité c'est
on se réjouit tous évidemment que dans
le top 20 ou le top 100 la musique
française soit très présente ce qui nous
importe c'est encore une fois la
diversité des esthétiques et dans les
esthétiques il y a notamment
monsieur sénateur des esthétiques qui
font appel aux musiciens on peut
effectivement
beaucoup capitaliser sur des des
esthétiques qui d'ailleurs marchent pas
mal du tout à l'export du type musique
urbaine ou électro ce sont des
esthétiques aujourd'hui qui sont somme
toute assez faciles à produire je dis
facile au niveau financier ça ça
nécessite très peu de moyens en revanche
toutes les esthétiques du type classique
jazz même le rock ou même la chanson
française aujourd'hui qui sont des
esthétiques qui sont très peu rémunérés
sur le streaming très peu il faut le
savoir parce que le modèle de
rémunération du streaming favorise la
concentration des écoutes autour de
certains artistes de ce doute de
certaines esthétiques qui sont écoutées
de manière très massive c'est la part de
marché d'une esthétique qui produit la
rémunération et non pas l'écoute réelle
de l'artiste en question donc ce qui
nous importe aussi c'est de pouvoir
s'agissant de ces esthétiques là qui
vous l'aurez deviné coûte beaucoup plus
cher produire de faire en sorte qu'elle
puisse continuer à être produite un
label qui aujourd'hui n'est pas
suffisamment rémunéré en streaming et ne
bénéficierez pas d'un soutien financier
par exemple émanant du CNM ne serait pas
en capacité de poursuivre cette activité
alors je vous le dis tout net parce que
effectivement le la question de est-ce
qu'on est en tira ou je ne sais quoi
était posé moi j'ai autant des labels
qui font du rap qui adorent le rap que
des labels qui font du classique la
question n'est pas la question c'est
est-ce qu'on est en mesure de créer un
mécanisme redistributif qui va permettre
à ces esthétiques moins favorisées sur
le streaming tout simplement de survivre
voilà c'est une question qu'on pose
aujourd'hui et qui est une question
largement partagée pourquoi parce que
effectivement les artistes interpètent
les musiciens sont également concernés
parce que les labels sont concernés
parce que la diffusion est concernée
nous sommes tous concernés par la
nécessité de conserver une manière de de
quelque part de de faire en sorte que
toutes les esthétique puisse continuer à
être produite elle n'apporteront pas
toujours toute le même revenu mais
néanmoins c'est notre diversité celle à
laquelle nous sommes si attachés elle
dépend tout simplement de la capacité à
percevoir du revenu qui sera réinjecté
après dans la production et et enfin
nous permettra notamment de autre chose
de ne pas voir nos productions par
exemple de classiques être produite à
l'étranger
merci je vais vous donner la parole vous
allez aux autres successivement en
commençant donner la liste comme ça vous
savez vous positionnez Sonia de la
pauvreté Sylvie Robert Alexandra borcio
Fontain Jérémy Baki lors d'Arcos
Catherine Morin de saillie Pierre
ouzouillas et Jacques Robert
oui merci beaucoup donc il y a déjà eu
beaucoup de de réponses et de réflexion
notamment sur cette idée de la maison
commune parce que elle est certes
commune mais pas complètement comme
dirait comme dirait l'autre
avec notamment les questions d'équité
territoriales et des choix
d'accompagnement des collectivités
territoriales qui créent finalement de
la dysharmonie on va dire comme ça au
delà des union dans certains territoires
mais on a vu aussi les échanges
médiatiques qui ont montré que l'unité
n'était pas toujours là quand on devait
défendre son propre précarié et que donc
il reste encore quelques sujets à régler
il y a le problème du financement parce
que le modèle économique c'est monté à
un moment ou un certain nombre de sujets
n'étaient pas là je pense que c'est un
vrai sujet parce qu'il y a des défis
énormissimes enfin il y a les questions
RH la question des cachets le
développement durable qui est structurel
pour le coup c'est des vrais coûts
importants qui vont s'imposer à la
filière le décret son pour parler que de
celui-là mais
assurance aussi les questions
assurantielles je pense au festival
notamment avec les problématiques
climatiques ou sanitaires et puis toutes
les problèmes de fonctionnement de
fluide de matières premières etc et on
voit bien que la question des surcos en
réalité risque de fragiliser
complètement l'existence même du CMNM si
le CNM a pas les moyens de répondre de
sécuriser la présence des acteurs et la
diversité des acteurs dans les
territoires donc cette question là elle
déborde finalement le cadre du
fonctionnement est presque les échanges
qu'on a maintenant sur une taxe
streaming c'est-à-dire qu'on est
vraiment face à une structuration de
l'accompagnement qui répond à tous les
objectifs qui avaient été identifiés au
départ dans le texte de loi pour la
création du CNM il y a un défi dont vous
n'avez pas parlé c'est celui des JO 2024
où on entend dire dans les échanges que
2023 certes mais devine 24 va être un
vrai sujet puisque va s'ajouter à ça des
considérations budgétaires de
renchérissement des coûts de sécurité
etc donc
et de raréfaction d'un certain nombre de
ressources humaines donc ça c'est ce
sujet donc que vous
ça signifie que on doit avoir des
perspectives budgétaires pour 2023 mais
que le débat là prend en compte déjà la
question de 2024
un autre sujet et celui
de l'observation vous l'avez évoqué
plusieurs fois elle doit être impartiale
cette observation parce que faute
d'observation impartiale
on arrive au débat ou au polémique
actuels et surtout on n'est pas en
capacité de défendre à terme un
véritable budget d'accompagnement et de
structuration des aides 2023 2024 et
pour la suite puisque de toute façon la
filière aura besoin d'être accompagné et
enfin ma dernière question pour se porte
sur les l'éducation artistique et
culturelle qui faisait partie des
missions
du CNM alors je reconnais que ça n'a pas
été simple c'est depuis la création il
n'empêche que le discours même là on
voit bien dans la présentation est
plutôt pour employer un terme normand
tes œufs sur le sujet sur le sujet et
que pour le coup
l'éducation artistique et culturelle
c'est aussi l'accès à la diversité
musicale et dans tous les territoires
pour ce qui fera demain le public adulte
et donc c'est un vrai sujet qui peut
conditionner les clés de réussite du
CNAM également
j'ai oublié de préciser que ce n'est de
la pauvreté et présidente du groupe
d'études qui suit les festivals
Sylvie Robert
merci monsieur le Président bonjour
messieurs
donc d'abord j'aurai trois questions
précises une rejoindre d'ailleurs celle
de Sonia mais je vais la développer un
petit peu et puis donc réponse à
question précise c'est important d'avoir
des réponses précises c'est pour ça que
je vais aller vite mais en préalable je
voudrais d'abord moi saluer l'action du
CNM nous l'avons défendu nous l'avons
soutenu nous avons voulu transformer le
CNV en CNN c'était une ambition
importante et aujourd'hui je crois que
nous devons partager cette ambition et
en tout cas puisque apparemment le PLF
2023 n'est plus un sujet on sent bien
que le point de l'importance du PLF 2024
alors c'est pas un sujet oui c'est un
sujet mais
aujourd'hui on va essayer mais c'est on
voit bien que c'est la ministre
elle-même a dit à pas de il y a pas de
problème de financement le directeur a
fort justement dit que
il y en a un mais la capacité pour nous
de le résoudre ou en tout cas d'avoir
mais ça c'est peut-être une question
qu'on posera la ministre la semaine
prochaine d'avoir une solution
transitoire sur 2023 ce qui est
différent d'inscrire structurellement
une réforme du CNM dans un PLF voir même
c'est un peu différent c'est pour ça que
je fais je fais la
comparaison et je pense que pour cela je
crois que le préalable c'est quand même
la défense de l'intérêt général moi je
voudrais le dire parce que derrière
au-delà de la défense de l'intérêt
général c'est la capacité de tous les
acteurs de la filière et nous l'avions
redit à la fois être solidaire à pouvoir
travailler sur la redistribution comme
disait monsieur côté et à se dire que la
question du partage de l'investissement
et de la valeur ajoutée pour atteindre
de la finalité qui est l'ambition de ce
CNM doit être vraiment au rendez-vous je
voulais commencer par là parce que ça
n'est pas anodin et et je crois qu'il
faut en avoir conscience et les
polémiques sur rap anti CN n'ont pas
servi cette cause je voulais dire et
quand Jean Raymond le dit dit pourquoi
c'est arrivé à ce moment-là dans le
débat public c'est vrai que ça n'aurait
pas dû arriver et je trouve que ça ne
sert pas en tout cas la cause que nous
défendons tous en tout cas depuis le
début au Sénat trois questions précises
la première je vais revenir puisque
Sonia l'a évoqué et Monsieur coté l'a
dit observation impartiale moi je trouve
que la question de l'observation et la
remontée des données est absolument
centrale parce qu'aujourd'hui forcément
il y aura des impacts sur la question de
ces données je voudrais savoir comment
se déroule le processus
est-ce que il y a des garde-fous comment
vous garantissez à la fois la fiabilité
la sincérité et l'objectivité des
données c'est à dire comment en fait
c'est organisé le processus ça c'est un
point méthodologique qui pourrait être
très technique mais qui est extrêmement
politique parce que derrière vous
imaginez qu'en fonction des des
remontées des données il y a des choix
qui sont faits la seconde question m'est
venue en vous écoutant moi je voudrais
savoir si vous êtes tous d'accord sur le
fait que si taxes sur le streaming il y
a ce sera le travail entre autre puisque
Julien a nous l'a bien dit à travailler
sur la filière musicale mais la taxe et
le financement du CNM en fera partie
est-ce que vous êtes tous d'accord pour
taxer les plateformes
à celles et ceux qui me répondraient
attention si on tape les plateformes les
abonnements vont augmenter moi quand je
vois le décret SMAT et ce qui se passe
dans l'audiovisuel aujourd'hui c'est pas
du tout le cas c'est pas du tout le cas
donc je voudrais que vous répondiez très
précisément sur le périmètre de la
taxation et si en tout cas vous êtes
d'accord pour mettre à contribution les
plateformes et puis une autre une autre
question qui est venue alors il s'avère
que je suis rapporteur pour avis sur sur
le budget spectacle vivant entre autres
et dans nos auditions de lundi dernier
et Sonia était présente elle pourra en
attester il y a une question qui est
venue qui est un petit peu préoccupante
c'est les critères qui prévalent sur
la distinction entre les festivals qui
relèveraient du CNM et ceux qui
relèveraient du fond festival et
apparemment dans les Dracs c'est à dire
et ce que c'est le fond festival qui a
été voilà pour les Dracs et il y a
apparemment sur les territoires parfois
des on ne sait pas très bien donc est-ce
que c'est juste est-ce que c'est un
vraiment en tout cas un constat qui que
vous partagez et est-ce qu'il y a des
critères précis qui pourraient enlever
cette tension parce que c'est un peu
dommage voilà moi je voudrais terminer
par là en vous disant que ce qu'on
attend
en tout cas pour ma part c'est une
vision vraiment stratégique de l'État
aussi son rôle de régulateur et surtout
sa capacité à pouvoir un moment revenir
sur des fondamentaux mais vous l'avez
dit c'est la question de la diversité
c'est la question de l'émergence et
derrière cela c'est aussi une question
stratégique et moi en tout cas j'attends
du gouvernement qui nous donne cette
vision stratégique j'imagine que le
fabuleux rapport de Julien va y
contribuer valider en tout cas quand
nous nous retrouverons j'espère qu'en
tout cas nous pourrons nous appuyer
aussi sur une vision un peu plus claire
du gouvernement sur la question voilà
Alexandra porche
[Musique]
monsieur
le président
[Musique]
suggère quant à lui de passer un système
plus équitable selon lui qui s'appelle
user centric pemen system celui-ci
rémunéré uniquement les artistes écoutés
par les abonnés des plateformes cela
permettrait donc de rémunérer plus
justement les artistes les moins écoutés
mais également redonner des couleurs à
la diversité musicale donc je voulais
savoir ce que vous pensiez de cette
proposition est-ce que selon vous elle
va produire les effets escomptés je vous
remercie
Jérémy Becky merci monsieur le Président
Monsieur mes chers collègues bon je ne
reviendrai pas longuement sur la
question de la taxe affectée mais quand
même juste un petit mot je partage
pleinement ce que vous avez énoncé
l'idée de dire il faut partir des
besoins regarder les besoins de la
filière et adapter ensuite les moyens
aux besoins si comme vous le dites et je
suis pas loin de partager les besoins
s’estiment à 50 millions d'euros on a en
réalité un trou dans la raquette de 20 à
25 millions d'euros et cela signifierait
en tout cas c'est la position que nous
défendons l'idée d'une taxe de 1,5%
justement sur sur l'ensemble des
plateformes sur deuxième question mais
très rapide sur la question des
festivals j'ai rencontré
bon nombre de festivaliers à la fin de
l'été qui me disait qu'ils avaient été
profondément touché cette année parfois
par le manque de personnel en capacité
d'organiser ces festivals on sait par
rapport à la période covid par rapport à
des reconversions
professionnelle de certainement
d'acteurs de ces festivals j'aurais aimé
avoir un peu votre sentiment sur ce
secteur qui est fragilisé encore plus
peut-être dans la période et qu'elle
pourrait être les pistes de travail pour
permettre le maintien notamment des plus
petits festivals ou des festivals de
taille moyenne qui ont les plus grandes
difficultés justement à recruter ou à
pouvoir éventuellement se tenir pour
certains d'entre eux troisième et
dernière question sur la question de la
diversité ça a été évoqué à plusieurs
reprises monsieur coté vous vous l'avez
évoqué est-ce qu'il y a pas non plus sur
cette question de la diversité un
travail pédagogique en amont pour
permettre justement à un certain nombre
de de de musique de pouvoir trouver leur
public parce qu'on se rend compte qu'en
réalité lorsque il y a un chanteur d'un
style musical qui apparaît il ne vient
pas empiéter sur d'autres styles
musicaux il se surrajoute en réalité à
l'écoute musicale et donc est-ce qu'on
n'a pas peut-être des pistes de
réflexion en ce sens pour dès le plus
jeune âge peut-être éveillé très
largement l'ensemble des styles musicaux
en tout cas c'est une réflexion sur
laquelle j'aimerais vous entendre je
vous en remercie
leurs Archos
oui merci beaucoup président ma question
sera très rapide on quitte un peu le
streaming pour revenir sur la
rémunération pour copie privée je
voulais savoir si vous aviez eu des
retours sur le rapport conjoint qui
avait été fait par
Liga qui est l'IGF je sais que vous avez
tous été sollicité moi aussi avec le
président Lafont et savoir si on avait
encore des choses à améliorer ou si vous
pensez que on arriverait quand même à
trouver un juste équilibre entre ce qui
avait été fait
dans le cadre de la proposition de loi
de Patrick chaise sur les les produits
reconditionnés et puis bien évidemment
vous rémunérations qui sont importants
pour votre secteur
Catherine Morin de Sailly
président
sur le mode de financement du CNM
j'aurais donné rapporteur à l'époque de
la loi la rappeler avec force et à juste
titre je me revois encore dans
l'hémicycle avec les interventions des
uns et des autres nous avons pointé du
doigt là-bas notre soutien à la création
du CNM comme aussi Sylvie et en même
temps
cet écueil qui avait en l'absence d'un
financement
identifié je veux bien qu'il y a eu la
crise de la covid qui a perturbé
peut-être un certain nombre de
fonctionnement mais tout de même trois
ministres plus tard deux ministres plus
tard pardonnez-moi on a toujours pas
pour cette loi de finance un modèle
voilà sur lequel on peut
s'appuyer il me semble que le CNM et je
voudrais à mon tour saluer tout le
travail du CNM pendant cette période de
crise mais les les comment dirais-je
après le temps de la filière le disent
tous heureusement que vous avez été là
certes vous avez été commencer par le
ministère dans le cadre du plan
d'urgence donc ça il faut aussi le
souligner vous n'avez pas manqué de fond
à redistribuer mais tout de même vous
avez fait votre travail vous avez prouvé
votre utilité dans la structuration de
de la filière donc je le regrette alors
il y a cette écueil du financement et
puis je rappelle aussi qu'à l'époque où
se crée la taxe sur les plateformes
notamment un taxi Youtube pour le cinéma
à l'époque nous alertons en disant
attention cette taxe aurait peut-être
comment dirais-je utilité à être affecté
à l'ensemble en fait les industries
culturelles la musique y compris on a vu
des débats et ses débats on les a eu à
nouveau lors de la création du CNM voilà
ce qu'on fera bien sûr pour suivre la
réflexion sur la taxation des
plateformes ça me semble tout à fait
légitime
financement et gouvernance alors c'est
le deuxième sujet qui est identifié non
pas la gouvernance
chers président de du CNM en tant que
tel mais plutôt la gouvernance de la
fille Vilaire dans sa diversité qui
renvoie en fait ce que vous avez
souligné le rôle du ministère la DGCA et
la direction la musique
quelle relation avez-vous à l'heure
actuelle et comment travaillez-vous avec
la direction de la musique moi ça
m'intéresserait de de le savoir vous
avez souligné juste ce titre de points
n'ont toujours pas été clarifié et on
les avait mis aussi sur la table lors
des débats qui ont présidé à la création
du du CNR à deux trois reprises on a eu
aussi l'occasion de le redire lors des
débats budgétaires à Franck Riester j'ai
eu moi-même l'occasion de le redire en
tant que président de l'Association
Française d'orchestre il y a 15 jours à
notre ministre de la Culture donc si
nous pouvions joindre nos efforts pour
avancer sur cette question de la
clarification
notamment des musiques de patrimoine et
de création comme vous l'avez dit ce
serait fort utile la question de la taxe
sur billetterie d'entrée dans les salles
je rappellerai juste l'exception que
fait la loi s'agissant des orchestres
dans la mesure où ce sont ils relèvent
de subventions publiques à
80%. donc il ne figure pas dans les
questions de billetterie voilà mais vous
avez raison il faut clarifier et ce
n'est toujours pas fait donc on aura
certainement un rôle à jouer ici au
Parlement et Julien barjean qui se lance
dans cette mission devrait aussi nous
aider à ce qu'on puisse avancer je
rappelle que la mission sur l'art lyrics
et la mission sur les orchestres est au
point mort c'est-à-dire qu'on devait
avoir des comités de pilotage qui se
poursuivent tout est lié dans cette
histoire de plan pour la musique n'ont
pas repris leurs travaux alors qu'ils
avaient été installés par Rosine
Bachelot donc tout ça a besoin d'être un
petit peu clarifié et qu'on est un vrai
plan pour la musique quoi voilà
merci Pierre ouzougas merci monsieur le
Président merci Messieurs chers
collègues
en écoutant le petit débat sur la taxe
affecté j'ai eu l'impression de revivre
celui sur la redevance
mais qui a été tranchée cher Julien
barjoton par le gouvernement puisque le
gouvernement a considéré que les les
fonds qui aident l'audios visuel public
devait être remis dans le budget général
donc je sais pas si c'est votre lettre
de cadrage mais si c'est le cas dans ces
cas-là il faut travailler autrement et
sur le débat sur la redevance moi je
regrette vivement avec le président de
la commission qu'on n'est pas eu un
débat de fond sur le mode de financement
du service public de la culture
qu'il finance et comment est-ce que
c'est le seul usager qui finance la
culture ou est-ce que c'est l'État sur
l'impôt avec une assiette la plus large
possible qui finance le service public
et si moi c'est plutôt ma conception du
service public et dans ces cas-là il
faut trouver une solution pour que
personne ne puisse s'échapper à l'impôt
et je pense bien évidemment
plateforme et au gafam parce que il y a
une distorsion de concurrence que vous
n'allez pas régler par une taxe affectée
donc là il y a il y a un vrai problème
d'enjeu et de politique publique par
ailleurs le parlementaire que je suis
est fatigué d'avoir à discuter tous les
ans au moment du budget d'une vingtaine
d'une trentaine de taxes affectées pour
la culture le mystère de la culture est
celui qui a le plus grand nombre de
taxes affectés ce qui ne donne plus
aucune visibilité politique sur le
budget de la culture il y a des il y a
des programmes d'opérateurs il y a des
financements d'opérateurs mais où est le
programme de la culture où sont les
ambitions de la culture on nous renvoie
chaque opérateur je pense que c'est pas
une bonne solution merci monsieur le
président
merci Jacques gros Perrin
merci président j'avais trois questions
mais la première tombe parce qu'elle
était posée aussi par Catherine Morin de
saillie sur le financement vous avez
compris l'importance en tout cas nous
inquiétude sur ce qui se passe la
deuxième question c'est
contrairement pas contrairement mais
dans ce qu'a dit tout à l'heure j'aurais
mon Hugonnet sur le développement
durable et l'environnement qui n'est
peut-être pas une priorité mais le CNM
ne doit favoriser en tout cas la
contribution de la musique assez de
protection là quels sont les modalités
concrètes et le bilan de cette action et
la deuxième question le Sénat étant la
chambre des territoires ce sont les
relations avec les collectivités locales
vous en avez parlé quelques peu tout à
l'heure
j'aimerais savoir quels sont les forces
et faiblesses les difficultés la
modalité des échanges notamment
financiers et puis quel appui le CNM
obtient-il des cette relation et qu'elle
appuie pratique fournit-il aux
collectivités locales je vous remercie
merci me permettrait d'ajouter une
dernière question avant de vous laisser
répondre mais ça fait écho un certain
nombre de remarques singulièrement celle
de Pierre ouzouillas sur l'impact d'une
taxe quelle qu'elle soit et qui paye
l'attaque entre l'usager le
le diffuseur ou l'éditeur c'est un point
je pense important dans la réflexion qui
va s'ouvrir dans les semaines et les
mois à venir
merci Monsieur présent je sais pas
comment voulez-vous que nous procédions
parce que j'ai pris note de différentes
questions et peut-être de revendre
passer l'une à l'autre mais je me tourne
vers les collègues il faudra être sinon
en un pour 4 heures quoi même en tout
cas je vais essayer de répondre aux
questions qui s'adressent directement au
CNM et j'ai presque envie de dire
exclusivement au CNM et sur les
questions plus larges évidemment
partager la Parole
sur l'étude de l'observation évoquée par
Madame les sénatrices de la pauvreté et
Madame Sylvie Robert c'est un point
extrêmement important qui avait été une
des justification de la création du CNM
donc très concrètement nous avons une
Direction des études et de la
prospective qui a été
issue des forces du FC du du Bureau
Export et du CNV pour l'essentiel qui
comporte une dizaine de salariés nous
concertons de manière assez systématique
sur la méthode dire qu'on a besoin des
données des professionnels en matière de
taxes sur la billetterie c'est
automatique ça relève de la déclaration
de la billetterie donc on consolide au
fond les données que notre système
d'information permet de collecter en
revanche dès qu'on a une étude plus
qualitative sur user centric sur la
manipulation des stream sur la diversité
on a besoin des professionnels et donc
comme la loi ne nous donne pas de
capacité de de on n'est pas un service
fiscal ou l'Insee donc on conserve sur
la méthode on se met d'accord plus ou
moins facilement et ensuite on essaye de
maintenir cette confiance qui est
indispensable à la crédibilité de
l'étude et sur user centric on sait
aussi appuyer sur un prestataire
extérieur parce que c'était extrêmement
compliqué mais c'est un cas de figure
qui ne s'est pas reproduit et par
exemple l'étude sur la manipulation des
streams nous la faisons en interne à
100%
exemple est très intéressant Madame
Bachelot en débat à l'Assemblée je crois
nous avait confié cette mission sur la
manipulation des streams on a mis un an
et demi à se mettre d'accord et j'ai
failli comme président en établissement
sifflait la fin de la partie à plusieurs
reprises et c'est vendredi le dernier
tardivement que finalement nous avons
fini par recueillir les données alors je
m'apprêtais à faire un constat d'échec
sur le fait qu'il y avait pas de
transparence certains acteurs ont joué
le jeu tout de suite pourquoi pas les
citer cobles Deezer Billy en revanche
d'autres traîner les pieds se renvoyer
la balle
brandissait des plutôt de dresser des
rideaux de fumée et puis finalement on a
les données et donc on va pouvoir
travailler et grâce aussi à l'aide du
SNEP que je salue on va pouvoir avancer
voilà donc c'est comme ça que nous que
nous fonctionnons au-delà c'est un enjeu
fondamental parce que les organisations
professionnelles les syndicats ont un
rôle d'observation
qu'ils se sont construits parce que au
fond ça intéressait quand même pas grand
monde au sein de la sphère publique
pendant des décennies pour les
certifications export c'est le Bureau
Export nous avons repris pour les
certifications disques d'argent etc etc
c'est le snap qui organise ça et il le
fait très bien simplement je pense que
dès lors que maintenant il y a un
établissement
qui a cette mission d'observation il
faut qu'on travaille pour non pas
objectiver au sens où ça serait pas fait
de la bonne manière mais ou qu'on puisse
dire le CNM maison commun de la musique
dit c'est ça les résultats y compris
parce qu'il y a des dispositifs derrière
qui en découlent comme accès à des
crédits d'impôts ou l'excès à des aides
publiques et c'est un tout petit peu
gênant sur le principe pas parce que
c'est mal fait sur le principe que des
aides publiques ou des crédits dépendent
de certifications données par des
organisations privées et encore une fois
sans remettre en cause la qualité de ce
travail qui s'est construit pas à pas et
que je ne remets pas du tout encore
sur l'observation alors sur Market
centrique user centric madame la
sénatriceter qui est sorti en janvier 21
sur qu'est-ce qui se passerait si on
passerait demain si on passait demain en
user centric c'était une photographie ça
montrait que ça provoquerait des
mouvements sans changer la vie du soir
au matin d'esthétique marginalisée en
termes d'écoute parce qu'augmenter de
25% la rémunération
d'esthétique très peu écoutée 25% de pas
grand chose ça fait quand même pas grand
chose c'était la photographie
maintenant le marché du streaming se
développe et une photographie c'est
quand même c'est génial très beau etc
mais c'est que moins intéressant qu'un
film disons ou une succession de
photographie donc il faut qu'on continue
à étudier mais en observant qu'il s'agit
de relations contractuelles privées
entre des plateformes des fournisseurs
de de données des labels et que
l'établissement public est peut-être
même législateur je suis pas très sûr de
ce qu'on peut y faire de se une relation
contractuelle de ce type donc continuez
à éclairer continuer à mettre en valeur
tel ou tel mouvement qui serait
déclenché par une par cette évolution on
en est un peu là et j'avoue que depuis
l'étude de janvier 2021 on s'est arrêté
il y a pas eu de suite si ce n'est la
manipulation des streams sur lequel donc
on sortira d'ici le début décembre
sur les les festivals
quelques mots oui il y a des vrais
craintes pour tous les motifs que j'ai
indiqué en termes de diversité en termes
d'offres alors vous m'avez interrogé sur
l'explication c'est le baisse de la
fréquentation mais Olivier Darbois
complétera je pense qu'il y a plein de
facteurs d'abord une offre très
abondante en 2022 parce qu'il y a eu des
reports parce qu'il y a eu
des festivals qui ont jugé que
économiquement ils s'en sortirait mieux
s'ils allongé leur proposition
or ils ont plutôt eu tendance à aggraver
à graver la situation sauf pour les plus
gros mais qui ont écrasé les autres
écraser c'est pas c'est comme ça quoi en
tout cas il y a eu une sur offre de
payant voire de gratuit des groupes que
je vais pas citer là mais on fait
30-45 ans date y compris dans des
manifestations locales subventionnées
par des communes ou des départements ou
des régions qui ont fait concurrence à
des manifestations payantes je l'ai vécu
dans ma région qui est qui est le sud
bon c'est ainsi offre abondante perte de
lien avec le public c'est la même chose
avec le cinéma c'est la même chose avec
le théâtre alors même que les
restaurants sont assez plats il y a eu
une déshabitue je sais pas comment le
qualifier en tout cas une perte
d'habitude d'acheter des billets
peut-être des questions de prix
évidemment et puis les festivals c'est
des déplacements donc c'est l'essence
etc etc en tout cas bon sur ce
diagnostic c'est une chose pour 2023 et
j'ai entendu là aussi le président du
prodige il y a quelques semaines dire
qu'il y avait un réexamen nécessaire du
modèle qu'est-ce qu'on propose à quel
public pour quelle qualité de
proposition et sûrement pour éviter de
proposer la même chose que le voisin à
100 km de là ce qui pose aussi des
problèmes de transition écologique parce
que c'est bien d'avoir la proximité et
si vous devez faire 100 km pour avoir
l'artiste que vous aimez bah le bilan
carbone il va pas être bon donc quand on
parle de cordature du cercle je pense
qu'on y est je me permets de continuer
aussi à propos des festivals sur le lien
avec avec les draps et et au-delà sur
les questions posées au ministère
évoquées par Madame assiatris Morin de
saillie et le sénateur Baki on y est pas
de mon point de vue quant à
non seulement sur les festivals je vais
l'illustrer mais aussi plus largement
sur articulation de l'opérateur et du
ministère pourquoi le dire pendant
longtemps le ministère a été réservé sur
la création d'un opérateur de la musique
parce que il y avait d'un côté à musique
subventionné noble auquel on
s'intéressait et puis après il y avait
la musique actuelle qui était largement
privée dont on s'est intéressé par long
dimanche de fiançailles à nouveau la loi
d'initiative parlementaire avec l'accord
du gouvernement a permis de créer le CNL
on n'a pas réglé toutes ces ambiguïtés
je pense qu'il faut on est en 2020 en
réalité ce qui nous rajeunit de trois
ans c'est la bonne nouvelle du jour mais
enfin et il faut se poser des questions
aujourd'hui quand ce serait posé en 2020
je crois que le ministère de la Culture
qui est notre direction de tutelle et je
le dis avec mon devoir de réserve doit
devenir parce qu'il ne l'est pas dans
certains domaines des un rôle
stratégique quels sont les objectifs
comment les évalue comment on sanctionne
le non respect des objectifs bref de
faire de la politique en faveur musicale
plutôt que d'aller gérer la subvention
d'ici ou de là pour les festivals j'ai
la faiblesse de penser qu'en 2021 avec
les fonds en place par par le ministère
nous avons bien travaillé avec les drags
parce que les draps connaissent le
terrain les Dracs il n'y aura pas de
délégation territoriale du CNM c'est pas
possible c'est pas le plan et on doit
travailler avec les drags et en 2021 on
a une politique pour les festivals où
nous avons géré tous les crédits pour
tous les festivals y compris le
classique d'accord
et pour que les dragues ne se sentent
pas écartés on a transformé nos méthodes
de travail pour que la Commission
festivale examine tous les dossiers
d'une région en même temps et le Drac
était là on a régionalisé nos ordres du
jour alors certes c'était nous qui
gérions les crédits mais un opérateur
c'est normal qu'il opère et les draps
apportaient leur regard et il y a eu en
fin d'année dernière les États généraux
des festivals qui ont qui sont parvenu
pour des raisons que j'ai pas tellement
envie de qualifier à un arbitrage
différent en disant bon bah les
festivals dans le champ de la taxe ça va
être le CNM puis le festival classique
ben on va les donner au DRAC mais il y a
pas les commissions dans les dragues et
j'ai du respect pour le travail des
dragues mais il y a pas de les
conditions nous les vôtres nous les
concertons nous les votons en conseil
d'administration elles sont publiées
c'est des commissions de professionnelle
qui examinaient dossiers qui proposent
les aides que ensuite l'établissement
des livres et je crois que c'est une
bonne manière de travailler et je dis
que l'arbitrage qui a été rendu que
j'applique naturellement en décembre
2021 dans les états généraux des
festivals étaient un arbitrage
administrative au je ne sais quoi mais
pas conforme à l'intérêt de la filière
et peut-être aussi des dragues voilà
qu'est-ce que j'ai besoin de dire de
plus je crois que c'était déjà pas mal
pardon alors sur les plateformes et
comme ça quand même relation avec
collectivités territoriale nous avons
mis 3 millions et demi d'euros en plus
des autres interventions je fais le tour
des régions en présence des drags pour
aller proposer de signer des contrats
qui sont tous différents à
Clermont-Ferrand on fait de la musique à
l'image et de la formation
professionnelle dans la région Centre
restant encore autre chose etc etc donc
c'est vraiment c'est pas l'idée de
guichet unique pas du tout du tout c'est
l'idée d'effet levier maintenant vu
l'état des finances locales qu'on nous
annonce je sais pas très bien qu'elle
sera le succès de cette démarche mais ça
permet vraiment de venir faire plus avec
les acteurs locaux sans créer de
machines administratives puisqu'en
général c'est le CNM et la petite équipe
de 4 collaborateurs qui gèrent ces
crédits c'est assez simple c'est assez
léger et à nouveau par votre voix
puisque vous représentez les les
collectivités territoriales de France on
est à disposition des élus pour
développer cette action qui me semble
aller dans le sens là aussi des acteurs
de la musique adaptés aux réalités de
chaque région sur la taxe sur la taxe
streaming je crois que je vais je vais
laisser parler les les
collègues sur le prix d'abonnement la
question que vous avez posé monsieur le
Président je pense que de toutes les
façons il y a une question de modèle
économique que les plateformes n'ont pas
encore trouvé
avoir accès à 100000 titres tous les
jours supplémentaires donc c'est des des
centaines de millions de titres pour
9,90 € avec c'est pas le juste prix
c'est sûr le problème c'est que il y a
de l'abonnement en streaming vidéo il y
a l'abonnement à la presse digitale il y
a l'abonnement externe etc et que il y a
sûrement une question d'élasticité mais
je pense qu'une taxe sur une chiffre
d'affaires
nationale de 1,5% ne peut pas pas être
l'argument pour augmenter les prix prix
qui sont déterminés à l'échelle bon je
rentre pas dans le détail de la prise de
ces décisions là mais je peine à croire
que mais il y a une question de prix
mais qui n'est pas liée à la taxe de mon
point de vue et d'ailleurs qui n'existe
un projet de taxe
festival ou sur d'autres sujets bien sûr
mais
alors pour continuer sur la taxe
streaming en définitive nous parlons de
quelques centimes sur des abonnements
d'une dizaine d'euros
et ne vous y trompez pas l'augmentation
des bureaux des Bordes des grandes
plateformes taxes ou Pat taxes
vous verrez les abonnements augmenter
dans les mois voire oui dans les mois
qui viennent donc en fait en réalité la
façon dont on le propose on propose une
assiette large avec une taxe très très
minime qui encore une fois
nous parlons de quelques centimes
je vais
c'était juste pour continuer sur le sur
la taxe streaming pour vous répondre
les festivals
alors le bilan est compliqué le bilan
est compliqué parce qu'il y a
effectivement tous les artistes qui
n'ont pas pu tourner en 2020 en 2021 ce
sont reportés sur 2022 voir également
sur 2023 créant un embouteillage
jamais vu une offre énorme avec des
festivals qui je le dis ont certainement
joué aussi la sortie de crise
c'est-à-dire on a été privé d'activité
pendant deux ans et bien l'euphorie de
la sortie de crise a certainement
produit chez les organisateurs de
festival une envie de rattraper un petit
peu le temps perdu d'augmenter le nombre
de journées de festivals d'en créer
d'autres parce que réellement les études
au sein du prodige ont montré qu'il y
avait 17% de nouvelles créations que ce
soit en journée ou que ce soit un
festival
je personnellement trouve que c'était un
petit peu prématuré dans le sens où
quand vous sortez quand vous êtes en
convalescence et notre secteur était en
convalescence en sortant de deux ans de
deux ans de crise
si vous voulez vous n'alignez pas je
l'ai je l'avais déjà dit à l'époque vous
n'alignez pas un
sportif en finale de
d'une Coupe du Monde une ou deux ou
d'une voilà d'une finale tout simplement
et donc il fallait certainement y aller
progressivement
donc bien entendu ça crée de l'inflation
parce qu'il y a l'inflation géopolitique
et la relation de que nous que tous les
secteurs connaissent aujourd'hui mais
cette embouteillage a également créé de
l'inflation avec bien entendu des
prestataires qui n'étaient pas tous au
rendez-vous vu l'abondance de demande et
bien entendu des vous l'avez souligné
énormément de personnels qui ont quitté
nos métiers pourquoi ils ont quitté nos
métiers parce que deux ans de crise si
vous voulez au bout d'un moment vous ne
voyez pas l'horizon et une grande partie
des cadres et des techniciens
spécialisés dans nos domaines ce sont
dit que voilà l'horizon étant très très
loin sans aucune sans aucune vision ces
gens ont tout simplement quitté nos
métiers il va falloir pour vous pour
vous répondre il va falloir travailler
avec le CNM certainement sur
aller dans les écoles aller dans les
dans les formations pour
faire renaître cette envie les métiers
du spectacle vivant c'est de la passion
avant tout si vous regardez les modèles
économiques du spectacle vivant c'est
extrêmement fragile extrêmement
compliqué donc il faut énormément de
passion pour faire ces métiers et je
pense que surtout bien entendu chez les
jeunes il y a une une nous aurons une
capacité mais grâce au CNM je le dis à
aller convertir l'envie des gens de
rentrer dans de revenir dans nos métiers
même si nous ne récupérerons pas les
cadres d'un certain âge qui sont partis
définitivement nous le pensons
sur la question du baromètre les études
d'observation
moi enfin
la taxe fiscale il n'y a pas meilleur
une des vertus de la taxe fiscale sur la
billetterie c'est aussi de pouvoir
donner l'outil c'est aussi un outil
d'observation c'est extrêmement plus
simple de partir à partir de partir de
l'existence c'est-à-dire l'obligation
pour tout le monde d'assumer cette taxe
et bien forcément conduira à un outil
extrêmement performant parce que dans le
passé les outils qui ont été mis en
place par le Ministère de la Culture
sont souvent très compliquées à
déchiffrer et très et
ne sont pas extrêmement
comment on pourrait dire
je manque oui voilà manque de
rationalité et puis alors très
sincèrement chez nous nous devons
déclarer tout à tout le monde donc il
serait enviable d'avoir une un
établissement centralisateur le CNM se
propose de l'être et en fait c'est dans
sa mission nous nous sommes absolument à
fond sur ces études d'observation menées
par le CNM et puis l'indépendance le CNM
est indépendant voilà
le je vous ai parlé des festivals le Zen
pardon les aides CNM vs les Dracs bien
là aussi le CNM est très très efficace
les dragues peut-être un peu moins parce
que il y a une certaine
en leur demande aussi beaucoup mais les
dragues doivent faire des choix et ces
choix ne sont pas forcément motivé par
des critères là où le CNM je peux vous
dire les sont bien existants ils sont
certainement perfectibles ne pas en
douter mais en tout cas les critères
sont bien sur la table et et
joue leur rôle
2024 quelqu'un posait la question de
2024 voilà alors Prodis
spectacle vivant privé nous avons
je vais pas vous remémorer tout mais je
veux le faire si c'est quand même très
simplement le Bataclan
les grèves les grèves les transports qui
ont été
assez compliqué les gilets jaunes
puis la crise du covid l'inflation et
bien 2024 nous avons les Jeux Olympiques
donc
nous ne pourrons pas accéder aux grands
équipements
et les grands concerts et les grands
festivals ne pourront pas effectivement
se déployer dans cette période qui va de
juin septembre c'est-à-dire un
abaissement de la taxe fiscale
certainement parce que les stades je
peux vous dire que depuis que nous avons
repris les activités
si certaines capacités certaines
esthétiques ne fonctionnent pas en
revanche les stades quand j'ai commencé
ce métier il y avait deux stades par
saison et très souvent c'était Johnny
Hallyday
aujourd'hui c'est une dizaine de stades
de France par saison
tous ces séances sont complètes à 98% et
ça suit également sur le sur les stades
en province dans les territoires
excusez-moi
les festivals les festivals subiront le
même sort pourquoi parce que les
événements sportifs vont bien entendu
préremper les les
capacités de production c'est-à-dire les
prestataires techniques les forces de
police nationale et également
les forces de services sécurité privée
donc de juin à septembre nous n'aurons
pas la capacité de nous déployer
notez-le parce que ça va affaisser la
taxe le rendement de la taxe fiscale
d'une façon drastique
voilà que puis-je vous dire d'autre je
pense que j'ai couvert tout sur sur le
spectacle vivant merci voilà Monsieur
essayeg il est un mot très rapidement
sur l'observation un point important le
CNM a beaucoup fait mais il dépend des
informations que lui donne les
plateformes et moi je vais être très
clair avec vous si on ne force pas d'une
certaine manière les plateformes à
renseigner et communiquer ces
informations nous dépendrons toujours du
bon vouloir d'édit de plateforme si CNM
a rencontré des difficultés pour mener
son étude sur les fausses stream la
manipulation des streams c'est pas de
son fait c'est parce qu'il n'avait pas
d'informations
précises demain si on veut vraiment un
observatoire de la diversité sur les
plateformes il va falloir que les
plateformes comme le font les médias
traditionnels renseignent très
précisément ces informations je vais
vous donner un exemple on parle de fonds
de catalogue un titre qui revient au
fond de catalogue est un titre qui a
plus d'un an mais peut-on
raisonnablement comparer un titre des
Beatles sorties dans les années 60 avec
un titre qui est sorti un an et demi
alors qu'ils sont rangés exactement dans
la même catégorie aujourd'hui c'est ça
c'est ce degré d'analyse que dont nous
disposons donc on a absolument besoin
que ces informations soient renseignées
alors c'est mieux que ça soit fait
spontanément mais si il y a nécessité
pour réguler à tout le moins pour que
les plateformes ont renseigne ses
informations tant en terme de diversité
qu'en termes ce qu'elles font pour
lutter contre la manipulation des stream
ça me semble vraiment essentiel pour
répondre à Madame sur la taxe streaming
oui sous réserve qu'elles soient
raisonnable et qu'elle soit adaptée je
dirais qu'il y a deux paramètres à
prendre en considération le premier
c'est que toutes les plateformes
n'évoluent pas dans le même secteur vous
avez des plateformes qui sont des pures
players qui ne dépendent et qui ne
vivent que de la musique et puis vous
avez des entités qui sont un produit
d'appel dans les grands groupes qui font
bien d'autres choses que de la musique
et quand on dit que les prix des
abonnements vont augmenter mais je
partage pas cette optimisme ou ce
constat moi j'observe que le revenu
moyen de l'utilisateur sur le streaming
musical il a baissé depuis 5 ans il
était à 7 euros il est à peine à 5 euros
aujourd'hui pourquoi parce que 1 vous
avez eu une stagnation du prix faciale
mais surtout vous avez le développement
d'offres alternatives enfin étudiante
offre famille bundle six mois gratuits
que bien évidemment ces plateformes
répercutent sur les titulaires de droit
donc c'est compliqué le streaming c'est
pas simplement un prix qu'on montre et
il y a beaucoup il y a beaucoup de
formulations beaucoup d'offres il faut
être très vigilant mais je ne pense pas
c'est sûr que si la taxe est modérée
cela entraînera une augmentation du prix
je partage
de Jean-Philippe sur sur ce point market
centrique user centrics c'est la même
chose Deezer nous avons dû les vertus du
user centric pourquoi pas mais à
condition de pouvoir vérifier s'ils font
vraiment ça crée plus de diversité c'est
vrai qu'aujourd'hui on a une loi de
Pareto exacerbée en matière de streaming
généralement 20% faisait à 80 % des
ventes dans le domaine du physique
aujourd'hui d'après une étude réalisée
par l'autorité britannique de la
concurrence
1% des titres font 80% des stream donc
c'est cette règle qui s'applique
aujourd'hui vous avez en 2020 plus de 50
millions de titres étaient disponibles
sur les plateformes il y en avait à
peine 4 millions qui ont exprimés au
moins une fois et 1% c'est à dire à peu
près 40 000 on représenter une
volumétrique 80% des streams alors ça
fait quand même 40 000 titres vous me
direz mais c'est vrai c'est une vraie
question donc pour répondre à cette
question il faudrait suivre pendant un
an voir deux ans et faire un comparatif
on peut pas faire on peut pas faire par
échantillonnage parce que ça se mesure
au titre mais ça se aussi au catalogue
et très sincèrement on a besoin là
encore de donner robuste de la part des
plateformes on peut pas simplement se
contenter de ce qu'a fait 10 heures je
vais le dire d'appliquer un coefficient
pour augmenter la valeur ou pour la
baiser pour la baisser c'est absolument
pas la méthode à suivre
diversité je crois qu'on y a répondu je
vais pas y revenir baisse des
fréquentations aussi importants on
constate nous la SACEM un nombre
important de séances occasionnelles
menée par des petites structures qui
baissent de manière drastique et qui
contribue bien évidemment à la collecte
des droits d'auteur de manière
significative donc c'est un sujet de
préoccupation enfin on a posé une
question sur la copie privée on attend
aussi le résultat de l'étude la seule
chose que je voudrais dire c'est une
petite anecdote parce que quand j'ai été
auditionné on m'a expliqué que c'était
un dispositif obsolète et le lendemain
la Cour de justice de l'Union européenne
rendait un arrêt qui appliquait la copie
privée au cloud computing alors moi je
veux bien qu'on m'explique que le cloud
computing c'est quelque chose de mais
j'ai pas le sentiment aujourd'hui compte
tenu des évolutions dans ce secteur que
ce soit un dispositif obsolète et la
Cour de justice dit dans son arrêt qu'il
est du devoir du législateur de
préserver une neutralité technologique
et de s'adapter en fonction des
nouvelles technologies donc aujourd'hui
on a une plasticité de la copie privée
qui permet d'appréhender bien évidemment
les nouveaux usages on terminerai par là
merci rapidement et pour répondre en
particulier à Madame Robert sur la
question de la mise à contribution des
des plateformes est-ce qu'on souhaite
les mettre à contribution il faut
constater comme vient de le faire David
que les plateformes ça n'est pas un
ensemble homogène et on a la chance
d'avoir
sur le marché de la musique enregistrée
des plateformes européennes qui sont
leaders en France et je parle évidemment
de Spotify et Deezer on a aussi la
chance d'avoir un écosystème très riche
de start-up de de plateformes
européennes et françaises qui font vivre
la musique et les créateurs je pense en
particulier à koboz ou anomadaire
énormément d'autres entreprises de de la
musique tech donc est-ce qu'on souhaite
mettre ses acteurs là à contribution ces
acteurs européens qui reversent déjà 70%
de leurs revenus aux ayant droit est-ce
qu'on souhaite les mettre davantage à
contribution quel que soit le niveau de
cette contribution ma réponse est claire
non parce qu'en revanche il y a des
plateformes et était cités également qui
elle ne joue toujours pas le jeu malgré
la directive droit d'auteur malgré sa
transposition en droit français de de la
rémunération de la création et en
particulier musicale et on les a cités
ce sont en particulier les plateformes
de partage vidéo Facebook TikTok et les
autres donc
Madame Catherine Morin de saillie a
rappelé que lors de la création de la
taxe sur les services vidéo gratuit la
question se posait déjà de savoir si cet
axe devait ou non profiter à la musique
en parallèle de son apport
ocnc à l'époque évidemment le Cnam
n'existait pas donc ça n'a pas pu être
prévu mais mais voilà c'est le sens de
la proposition que l'on porte au snap
c'est d'aménager cette TSV sans rien
retirer au CNC pour que ces plateformes
qui encore une fois ne rémunèrent pas
suffisamment la création musicale
participe et donne leur juste écho
également au CNM
oui merci je vais évidemment réagir aux
différentes interventions relatives à la
taxe streaming sur
user centric j'aurais éventuellement des
choses à dire mais je pense qu'il s'agit
d'un débat à limite ça mériterait une
autre table ronde donc je vous encourage
éventuellement à relancer ce sujet là en
tout cas c'est un dossier qui a avancé
ces derniers temps et nous serons ravis
de d'y contribuer sur la taxe streaming
j'aimerais dire des choses et quelque
part redire aussi notamment ceux qui a
ce que vient de de dire David
toutes les plateformes doivent être
concernées ça nous semble une évidence
autant YouTube que Spotify pour quelle
raison si vous prenez la taxe sur la
vidéo tout le monde l'a paye c'est aussi
simple que ça c'est une taxe à 5 15 qui
est payée par YouTube et qui est payé
par Netflix
si nous décidions dans la musique de ne
taxer entre guillemets que certaines
plateformes elle seraient tout à fait
fondée à invoquer une rupture d'égalité
devant l'impôt donc ça nous semble
juridiquement risqué après nous avons
toute confiance évidemment dans les
pouvoirs publics pour expertiser ce
sujet et
attribuer les mérites et les
défaillances aux différentes
propositions
ce que nous en tout cas sur le scénario
de répercussion notre approche nous elle
est elle est simple on a entendu tout et
son contraire on a entendu que ça allait
être répercuté potentiellement sur les
ayants droits on a entendu que ce serait
répercuté sur les revenus des
plateformes enfin pris en charge par les
plateformes on a un petit doute
là-dessus on a entendu que ce serait
éventuellement pris enfin répercuter sur
le les abonnements
la quel que soit le scénario au final on
personne et aujourd'hui en capacité
absolument personne en capacité
aujourd'hui de déterminer quel va être
le le modèle de répercussion une chose
est sûre c'est que si nous en sommes
arrivés à proposer un taux extrêmement
en bas c'est pour que quel que soit le
scénario de répercussion qui soit à 100%
ou partiellement sur les uns ou les
autres c'est que cet impact soit
indolore
voilà c'est aussi simple que ça est-ce
que sur imaginons même qu'il y ait dans
le pire des cas une augmentation de 1,5
% de l'abonnement sur un abonnement à 10
euros ça fait effectivement une poignée
de centimes est-ce que ça va vraiment
perturber l'équilibre économique des
plateformes j'exprime le plus sérieux
doute sur la question des résiliations
puisque c'est un argument qu'on a
souvent entendu qui a souvent été
opposé notamment dans cette période où
le coût de la vie augmente et où
certains sont amenés à faire des choix
nous n'avons pas constaté de mouvements
de fond sur un grand nombre de marchés
on a vu ça un petit peu au Royaume-Uni
mais je vais vous dire la différence
surtout elle tient entre une différence
de taille entre l'audiovisuel et la
musique dans l'audiovisuel prenons la
France si vous voulez avoir accès à
l'intégralité du catalogue disponible en
France vous devez cumuler les
abonnements parce qu'on est dans une
logique d'exclusivité donc vous allez
avoir un abonnement Netflix Disney
Amazon MUBI la cinétique que sais-je
alors que dans la musique un seul
abonnement est nécessaire et vous avez
accès à l'intégralité du catalogue de 3
2 3 exceptions près donc en fait on
imaginant même que dans le pire des cas
le consommateur assume cette
répercussion en tous les cas de notre
point de vue elle sera minime et elle ne
conduira pas à abandonner le
l'abonnement auquel l'utilisateur ou la
famille a pu souscrire
merci messieurs pour vos interventions
et les réponses à nos questions vous
avez vu qu'elles étaient nombreuses nous
suivons avec attention la question de de
la musique depuis de nombreuses années
on avait été actif vous le savez au
moment de la teste de loi et on
continuera de l'être évidemment nous
travaillerons avec notre rapporteur par
ailleurs dans quelques jours
parlementaire en mission sur ce sujet
mais ça ne l'empêchera pas que la
Commission avance et elle le fera
puisque à un moment je
c'est pas à quel moment mais à un moment
la question législative se posera et
donc la décision vote des parlementaires
interviendra et c'était bien dans cet
esprit aussi d'essayer de poser les
termes du débat de manière sereine et
sérieuse que nous avons invité ce matin
je vous remercie aux uns aux autres de
vos contributions et le dialogue bien
sûr ce poursuit